The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
My night all day.
Oh,
hello.
Sweet pitches.
That's right.
We're back with the cast
of kill Tony the mat.
What would you be?
The composer.
What's a maestro?
The Maestro of kill Tony
Young Tony Hinchcliffe.
Thank you.
Hello.
Uh,
young and beautiful.
Sarah wan Shank and young and beautiful.
Kimberly condom.
Hi there.
Hello everybody.
Yeah,
if you guys don't know the show,
it's a podcast on the desk squad
podcast network where these two gals
courageously for over a year have done a
whole new minute of standup every week,
which takes fucking mad
testicles that you don't possess.
It's not courage,
intestinal fortitude.
Um,
but my point is you guys,
you guys did something that I don't
think anybody's ever done in that you've
documented your entire
standup comedy career.
Right?
Is it true both of you,
all of your sets were on it or did
any of you do sets before that?
I did sets.
But you did sets before you did
all of your sets on the show.
Yeah.
My first night at the comedy store,
uh,
was my,
the,
my first night going up was on killed.
Tony Dunne is so crazy.
Yeah.
That's so crazy.
And you've been doing
that for how long now?
Uh,
about a year and four months now.
That's every week.
Is that your first time
ever on stage right there?
No,
that's us.
Uh,
a few weeks ago.
Is that Sarah Kim?
I can't see.
It's all blurry.
It's Sarah.
It's Dave Attell and Jimmy Schubert.
Powerful.
Sarah,
look at you up there.
Rep Dance.
That's a check.
I love those pants.
No girl would ever look at
a picture of herself and go,
God,
I love those pants.
Or no dude.
Rather point being,
um,
if I had to go back and
watch my old standup comedy,
I'd probably throw up,
I'd probably have a heart attack.
I'd probably be like,
oh my God,
I'll never be able to do this.
Like I sucked so hard.
I'll never be able to make it.
But you,
you,
you fucking ballsy chicks have done,
I can't,
I need a better word.
All the luggage.
It's true though,
but it is ballsy.
Whatever it has me.
You guys have fucking
done some crazy shit.
I mean doing that in front of every like
every week doing a whole new minute of
standup comedy.
Yeah,
it takes a lot.
It's hard and especially now we're getting
into like over 80 weeks and so you're
like squeezing out every little bit
of anything funny that happened.
Do you go back and like capture your,
the stuff he did in the earlier episodes
and tried to turn it into like a longer
bit?
Yeah.
Well sometimes I'll,
I'll,
I'll listen to the older
ones and I'll be like,
what else can I talk about and make new
like tags and I'll just use those tags
as my new joke.
Yeah,
no,
I too,
I totally get it.
Yeah.
Kill Kill.
Tony is a podcast that Tony Hinchcliffe
started with Brian and you guys figured
out a really delicious plan and
it's have comics go up for a minute.
Just a minute.
You a minute of standup and then
you have pros just either say,
hey,
that was really funny.
Like that bullets and bricks guy.
We were like,
hey,
fucking good shit dude.
You could really be a calm,
I click you're a comic work at
this and you can be a comic.
Or you know,
like some people like,
oh my God,
what was this craziness
that I just saw her?
Right.
And you get a chance to see like the
professional comics fuck with these people
or you know,
get excited about seeing
someone who's funny.
Yeah.
It's like if you hang out in the back of
the original room a lot where you know,
normal standup comedy takes
place or any comedy club,
you'll always see a bunch of comedians
in the back either standing around or
sitting down and they're always
whispering something in each other's ears.
And that I always thought found that
that to be some of the most interesting
stuff is getting,
you know,
more pros,
comedian perspective on what's
happening in front of them.
Sometimes they're like,
this person's going to be a star.
And sometimes it's like,
wow,
I can't believe this guy didn't
iron his shirt before coming out.
And that wide range of conversation that
happens between experience comedians
watching newer comedy
is always entertaining.
And I figured,
how do we turn that into a spontaneous
podcast that is refillable so people sign
up and there's a big bucket
and people get a new minute.
Some people travel from around.
We've had,
we just had somebody on the traveled from
Scotland to do kill Tony for his first
time on stage and so fuck you all right,
Australia every week it's somebody new.
So people like literally rather than
doing a bigger set somewhere else,
they'll purposefully start on kill Tony
because they listened to that show and
that's what made them realize or gave
them the inspiration that they'd like to
at least try to do this thing that
they've always inside one or to do.
So.
It's really fun getting to give people
that opportunity and have them be excited
about it and inspired.
Okay.
It's fun to do too.
I did it with dom Irrera and
we had the fucking best time.
It was so much fun.
And I think that one of the things
that I've been thinking about lately,
like because I did my special and I threw
out all my material and I'm starting
off with all new material,
I have to write a lot and I'm
just like in this like frantic,
frenzied mode.
One of the things,
it's really good,
it's like watching other people sort of
like try to piece it together and then
talking about like what
was wrong with that?
Why didn't that like,
what's an in,
in doing that you kind of do some stuff
that you ordinarily probably don't do
much with your stand up.
Like a lot of comics,
they record their sets,
very few listen to those sets,
right?
Most guys just record them and
then just go fuck that and just,
and just keep going for whatever reason.
But when you're forced
to analyze your stuff,
like I did a,
you know,
Ari has that podcast,
uh,
the skeptic tank and every now and then
he'll do an episode with a comic and
I'll play a CD and you
have to go over the CD.
And I went over the CD and as I was going
over and I was like thinking about all
kinds of things.
It was an old CD.
I hadn't listened to it and like six
years and as I was listened to us,
like there's like a lot of shit in here.
I would do different or nice.
See how I did that then,
oh Ooh,
I used to do that better.
Like I had this bit,
you know,
and you start thinking like
you can actually listen.
If you listen to yourself
from six years ago,
you could actually listen to yourself.
Like as an outsider,
like I know that it's me,
I recognize the voice,
but I barely remember the
material cause it's so long ago.
Yeah,
yeah.
About a month ago,
buddy came up to me or not even a buddy,
it was just a random guy and he goes,
man,
I saw you like five or six years ago.
You did that one joke about this thing
and I totally forgot that I did it.
Come to completely.
And I got so excited because I hadn't
heard that had anybody on kill Tony or
another comedian came
up with this premise,
I would have gone,
that's a great premise by the way,
just want to let you know,
I love what you're doing with
the blank and blank thing.
You know what I mean?
And I was so excited because it was
like he gave me this gift that was just
something that I did anyway that I didn't
remember that I did from five or six
years ago.
But that crazy enough is the joke that
he remembered me from this open mic from.
So it was amazing because yeah,
the perspective is different.
The joke that I do now off that thing
is totally different because I came with
uh,
a fresher,
more educated.
I'm more knowledgeable of who I am,
so I know how I really want to
do that joke that the fresh me,
Kate wrote the premise for it.
Right,
right,
right.
That's interesting though.
Yeah,
that's really cool.
In their house.
I've had that happen a couple of times.
When people come to you and they remind
you of a bit and then you're like,
oh shit.
Or sometimes,
you know,
I,
I listened to probably
half of my recordings,
I don't listen to all of them,
but I'm pretty diligent.
If I know that I got a
bunch of new stuff out,
I'll listen to it.
But every now and then I'll
listen to one and I'll go,
oh,
I forgot.
Oh my goodness,
I forgot that part.
And that part like makes
everything way better.
Exactly.
Where that part takes
it in another direction.
Yeah.
Every little,
every little thing that you can add on
when once you're already in a topic,
it's a huge gift because it,
not only is it just one show,
but once it,
once it's ingrained in the actual thing,
that means thousands and thousands of
people are all going to have that laugh.
Yeah.
I mean every show,
once it's part of the thing and
especially it only gets better.
So once it's a really working,
yeah,
they become like little living organisms
and the more you feed them and more
attention to give them,
the bigger they grow.
And sometimes you have to abandon them.
Like sometimes like,
oh,
this one's just bad.
It's just that it's down a bad road.
I don't know how to do this.
Right.
Like I have bits that
never made it to cds,
never made specials and nick,
sometimes they killed and
sometimes they didn't.
Sometimes it just doesn't know what
the fuck I was doing with them.
Yeah.
You know when you let go,
I don't want to do this anymore.
So just like I'm not married to this
just because I've been doing it.
Like you just got to abandon them.
That's what makes it so crazy
what you girls are doing it.
Yeah,
because you guys are going up and you're
doing a fresh minute every week because
you don't,
you don't get like a developmental cycle
when you're putting together a freshman
at every week.
You're just hoping that your ideas
are good when you get up there.
I mean you doing your sets like a couple
of days before you do kill Tony or like
how many,
when do you write your stuff out?
Oh go ahead.
I write mine all week.
Like I just write down jokes as much as
I can all week and then I try to work
them out before,
but sometimes I just pick one
and then I just build on it.
When on when you go that podcast and
you know that it's live and it's on the
Internet and then you're just going up
with this shit that you hope might work,
like what is that feeling like?
It's so scary.
Well,
Sarah,
it's,
Sarah does her as a week before and
a lot of the times I write mine,
like the day I'm going in,
I write it and you know what most,
a lot of the times when I write mine
the day of are the ones that do really,
really well because then I'm not as
nervous and it comes out more natural and
that's another thing I've
learned on killed Tony.
Just mostly like stage presence is a
huge thing because you have the live
audience too,
right?
You know,
so it's not like you're just
doing a minute on just a podcast.
What do you think that means?
Like what does stage presence mean?
Oof.
It's an interesting one in the,
because it means different
things to different people.
Right?
Like what,
what exactly does that mean
for me?
Just means like looking
confident and calm,
where I don't,
not having the audience being
uncomfortable watching you,
right?
Yeah.
That's a big one.
That's a bit longer
than you watch someone,
you know,
they're nervous up there.
You're like,
yikes.
Calm down dude.
You know?
Yeah.
And that's what's really cool is,
you know,
the,
the live audience watches the show and
they see names being randomly pulled out
of a bucket with 20 or 30 comedians
waiting to run from the top and come down
the stairs and be on the show.
You know,
they're going from a
viewer to an audience.
They're going from an
audience member to a comedian,
to a podcast guest,
and then thrown back out
in the belly room again.
So they're uh,
you know,
it's also so cool because they,
these two always go on at the
end of each show and every time,
especially even this last episode,
we just had the last comedian that I
pulled out of the bucket before I knew I
was going to that part.
It was an unbelievable interview.
Probably one of the biggest,
longest interviews we ever had.
We found out that this kid is living in
some big producers house by being half
gay and like half,
like teasing him with things
and being cute around the house.
But I'm producing sledding and
live in this around the house.
It's unbelievable.
This big producers letting
them live in this mansion.
We found out all this stuff and
think that nothing can follow that,
but what really does follow it?
And it even surprised me cause I'm like,
man,
I hope that that,
that it goes how it normally
goes is they come in,
even though that was crushing,
I had to send them off and go,
all right,
well this is the part of the show where
our two regulars go up and sure enough,
right when you thought it
couldn't get any better,
they just own it with exactly that thing,
which is that comfortable.
All of a sudden the audience is seeing
these two assassins who do this every
week and they can feel it.
Not only did they hear me say
it before when I bring them up,
but they,
you can really feel it because
if they couldn't feel it,
then they would just go,
wow,
these two,
you know,
I mean the GS,
they do this every week,
but instead it makes,
it's always the best
way to close the show.
It wasn't always that way,
by the way.
And that's what really the coolest part
is about this whole documentary thing in
my opinion is that yeah,
maybe some of the sets weren't
the best of this or that,
but they're,
you know,
not only does the audience get to watch
the overall growth for the ones which is
the many,
a lot of the diehard fans,
so many of them,
you know,
talk about that.
When they see me,
like in Toronto when we just did a theater
a few weeks ago with this show and so
many people were like,
you know,
getting to watch Kim and Sarah go from
how they were to these monsters that you
know,
it's pretty much a guarantee that you're
going to hear a brand new set of jokes
that is pretty good and it's going to be
a part of something bigger eventually.
So they get the first look at it,
which is cool.
Yeah.
Well you guys are doing is like you're,
you're coming up with new shit.
Like that's like the
hardest part of common.
He's coming up with new shit and
you're coming up with new shit.
Like as fast as anybody
is like a minute a week.
It's about as fast as anybody can do it.
I give you,
if you get lucky,
like every now and then you'll
hit like a five minute streak.
Like you got a new chunk and
it's five minutes long ago.
Oh,
I hit a gold mine.
You know when you start pulling bits
out of it or pulling taglines and and
premises and sidelines on,
and then you'll have one
that's like fucking 15 seconds
or one that's 20 seconds
here like this.
You can't get a minute.
You know?
If you have to get a minute every week
and a minute that you're going to stand
by and that's going to be on the Internet.
Oh,
good luck.
Yeah.
I think me and Sarah Gotten pretty solid
at knowing exactly what a minute is
too.
Maybe we end on with 58
it's crazy too.
Now they're the only two.
You know everybody else,
you'll hear the meow of a kitty at 60
seconds to let them know their time's up.
They'll just crushed,
crushed,
crushed and say good night.
And I looked down at the lower left
where Brian is the clock and it always is
(575) 085-0960
exactly.
I know exactly what a minute is cause I
take Lyft now and they're like you need
one minute to get outside and
they'll call me and I'm like,
oh I know I have 20 seconds left.
Like I know a minute.
Does that help at all in bed?
Yeah,
I know exactly.
The dude's like I gave
you 30 minutes of fury,
you're like 33 so it was seven and a half.
You're like I know.
Seven and a half minutes.
Yeah.
Well it's also crazy doing like a longer
set afterward like cause I'm so used to
these minutes.
So like going back and like just
everything was just tighter.
Yeah.
I was going to ask that.
Like what does it like doing like a dude?
What's the longest you guys have done?
Like 25 Oh wow.
What about you?
20 and 2025 and both of you have been,
you've been doing it a little over
a year and you've been doing it.
How long it close to three.
Close to three years.
So 2025 minutes that you would like you,
would you put it on a comedy special?
What'd you guys consider
doing a comedy special?
I wouldn't put 25 minutes on a car.
I wouldn't put 20 minutes
on a comedy special.
I don't know.
I'm comfortable with 15 minutes.
I like really have a,
I think I have a good 15 that's Brian's
idea actually to release 15 minutes
specials.
Yeah.
Like every two months release a 15 minutes
special and then like in like eight
months you'll have a an hour special.
That's true.
Yeah.
And then yeah.
Increments of comedy.
Yeah.
It's not about it.
And the other cool thing with their
thing is that they get to be in front of
those comedians.
Yeah.
You know,
we've met so many people.
Yeah.
It's so cool to get their perspectives to,
well,
the comedy store,
what since I've been gone
has grown like a measurably,
it's amazing.
It's such a different environment there.
Like you guys had always said
it was a different environment.
Then I started doing sets there.
I was like,
Whoa,
this is so different.
Like the new management staff and
the new regime running it there.
So on the ball it's like someone figured
out that there's this fucking gold mine
on sunset and a professional
management team started handling it.
Right.
I mean that's what it's like.
It's like a real comedy club now except,
but still like flooded with maniacs.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
When I got there,
which was right after you weren't
there just slip a couple months after.
Uh,
a lot of those rooms were
dark sitting there dark,
especially little take,
let's take it last night for example,
where that main room is just packed to
the gills and their show shows going on
though the belly room would set
dark most nights in the main room,
especially with sit completely dark if
it's just this giant 400 and whatever
seat room that you'd have to walk through
to go get the ladder to put new names
on the sign or whatever.
Yeah,
and that's what it was known as,
like that's what was happening.
But now every night,
and there's those,
these cool shows that are coming out.
Same thing with roast battle on Tuesdays.
Like that shows insane
Tuesday at midnight.
That changed.
That changed like 70
people's sleep schedules.
Yeah.
People wake up late on
Wednesdays now because of it.
Joe Was the show that brought me back.
I did a,
I went to see that the night before our,
he taped a special there and the
camaraderie and the fun in the air.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is like nothing else.
Yeah.
This place is like nothing else on earth,
and I just decided like,
oh,
why am I not coming here anymore?
Like this is a stupid,
yeah.
It just became ridiculous.
Like it's really obvious.
It's not the same place.
It's just there's this weird vibe there,
this chaos.
They're like,
you're doing a midnight show.
Okay.
And this place is packed with people
and they're just dissing each other and
when they're dissing each other,
people are jumping on the
stands and Jeremiah Watkins
and all his buddies there,
they have all these different
antics that they do in between.
It's fucking hilarious.
And why I was there,
I was like,
wow,
I can't even believe this.
This is really good.
Like what an environment like it,
you could feel like the,
I want to say like the creativity,
the,
the realness,
you could feel the authenticity of
the comics that were all hanging out.
Yeah.
And it's all just for us.
You know what I mean?
It's not like anybody's getting
paid for that or anything.
Like we're all just trying
to crack each other up.
Everybody's playing their,
their role.
And like you said,
when Jeremiah and Shamar
neighbors like on separated,
those two guys are monsters.
But when Jeremiah and Joe
Margaret near each other,
they tried out do each other.
We always talk about how
they're a modern day,
uh,
um,
Pryor and gene wilder.
Like there's something about when those
two they have to out goofy each other.
Right,
right,
right.
But when,
when they're together and they're in
their clothes where they'd been doing
comedy together for years being goofballs,
but now they finally have a
field where they can showcase it.
Dude,
people forget about
those prior gene wilder.
Okay.
Those movers were God damn
sensational at the time.
They were like the best
like comedy team ever.
And for whatever reason it
doesn't get discussed that much.
Like,
I enjoyed the shit out of those movies.
I don't know how they hold up today.
Have you seen one recently?
Yeah,
it's been a long time.
Yeah.
I would wonder.
It's sucks when like stuff
that you really liked.
Like I watched altered states.
You know that movie altered states about
the guy who turns into a monkey in a
sensory deprivation tank is William hurt.
Never saw that.
It was awesome in 1981 in 2014 you
fucking just giggle through it.
You're like,
what kind of a piece
of shit and my washing,
this is so fucking stupid.
And like I have such great reverence
for Richard Pryor and gene wilder.
I would hate to watch something
that they did and not enjoy it.
The new Beverly Cinema Theater right
around the corner from where I live that
Quentin Tarantino owns is actually playing
a two Richard Pryor specials back to
back and a double feature when,
um,
it's uh,
I think Friday,
December 19th.
You can look it up.
New plans send them a.com.
If I'm home,
I want to go to that.
Yeah,
that sounds right.
Imagine that in a movie theater,
$8 double feature.
They do a like $2 popcorn,
$1 sodas.
Why is Quintin Tarantino so cool?
It's unbelievable.
I have a,
I have a theory.
Have you seen him in person?
Yes,
the size of his hell.
I'd never seen him in person,
person,
whatever.
He's capturing and movies and stuff.
The angle on his head is to make it look
not as big as it is when you see him in
real life.
Hey,
listen,
not disadvantage.
No,
I'm telling you the
reason why he's so cool.
It's because he has four times the
brain matter that anybody else does.
Do you think that's what it is?
It it.
It cannot be coincidence.
His head is twice as big as
anybody else's in this room.
Like I'm talking like that Joe.
So you think you think there's
just more matter in there?
I just find it hard to believe that
it's coincidence that the guy with the
biggest head that I've ever
seen is also the genius.
Yeah.
He's also like a,
he morphs into like what
the people that he's around,
if you ever seen that,
like he was on Howard stern show once
and he was interviewed and he was talking
one way and then he was
on this all black show.
Yeah.
And he was being interviewed and it was,
you were just like,
oh no,
the Ab,
he fucking hammed it up so hard that I
was like holding on my pants pockets.
Like cringing like,
no,
don't do this.
No,
pull it out,
start talking white again.
Start talking about it again.
But I mean he was like,
yeah,
so we was,
we was doing this thing,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's so ridiculous.
Like have you seen it?
No.
You want to say it?
Yeah,
pull it up Brian,
because it's so ridiculous.
I guess we'll watch it on this thing
so we don't get pulled from youtube.
Take a shot if you're
playing the drinking game,
podcast pulled from Youtube.
Um,
but,
and again,
all due respect,
Quentin Tarantino,
I don't know the most respect.
Maybe that's what he really talks like.
And you can only be free
around black people.
It's white people.
Yes.
To Square it up cause we
just don't understand.
You guys don't get it.
Please.
I just love the fact that
he's so into film too.
You know,
he was talking about that about like
doing things on actual film and that the
look of film,
well that's why he's making the
lineups now at this theater.
Like he's owned the theater for years.
That's always been a thing.
Like it's like,
hey that's Quentin Tarantino's theater.
But a few months ago
he went in and the guy,
I guess that ms managing it or whatever,
put it in the new projector and he goes,
what's this like state
of the art projector?
And the guy's like,
ah,
yeah,
cool.
Right?
And he's like,
not cool.
You're done.
Goodbye.
I'm making the lineups
now you're out of here.
Something to that effect.
And so he makes the actual,
like the movies that play these double
features at his theater now are the
movies that he would want to see.
So does he like edit them and splice
them and stuff like that and put them in
the reels?
Like it's,
is it one of those real to real
things like the old school ones,
he doesn't go reel to reel.
He puts a five minute
and then her mission,
an old school thing that says
five minute intermission pops up
and then he up the other second reel on.
Right.
Wow,
whoa.
These are all the movies that
inspired him and like you,
there's probably little
things that you know he uses,
pays homage to and things.
And another cool thing is the previews
before these newbies or the previous that
for other of his mood for other movies
that are playing there later that month.
So you get to see the cool like
1980 preview for blank and blank,
like whatever you get to see.
I saw one when I went to see
unbreakable a couple of weeks ago,
uh,
for this Richard Pryor live and
the Prefuse for Richard Pryor live.
The ones that played are insane.
You would never believe these.
So different than any type of Promo.
What do you mean?
Like in what way?
Oh God no.
If that's something you'd
have to see to believe.
Like it's just it,
I can't remember exactly,
but it's just crazy.
If you look up like the trailer
for a Richard Pryor live,
I think the one for the sunset strip,
like I can't remember
exactly what's happening,
but I remember thinking if anybody did
a promo for their special like this was
done,
it would be all the talk.
Okay.
I don't know what you mean though.
Like in what way?
Like because every hire you right now.
Yeah.
Here's the Quentin Tarantino talking
like black people collect your thoughts.
Tony.
No.
For his,
his unconventional style
when it comes to film making one oh six
and please welcome director and Academy
Award Winner Quintero
that
film has to be like one of the most
quoted movies in Hollywood with just the
lines and everything.
So you got to give us,
this is one of my questions for you.
Your Cube.
What is the most famous like Yo,
your favorite line from pop fiction?
Uh,
I think probably the most famous
line is I'm going to get moody.
Baloney.
I ass.
He says it.
Okay.
How wasn't too bad or
pleasing the critics for you?
Oh,
interesting question.
Yeah.
Oh,
um,
well I want to,
I want to please my fans.
I don't want to please the
critics that I'm a fans.
Uh,
the critics,
even my fans,
I don't give a damn.
Wow.
That hurts my liver
doing is,
is fulfilling his vision.
You know this,
he's a visionary director for us too,
to have the opportunity to work with.
Okay.
Now I'm not that computer savvy,
so be it a sent me something that I plug
into my cheap robot would ever heard.
All right.
Download this.
I don't know how to do that.
For All I know
he might've been doing a character,
mighty said,
you know,
I hate doing these fucking shows.
I'm just going to see how black I
can get before somebody stabs me.
Right.
I say it's almost sounds
like he's mocking them.
Yeah.
Right.
I think he's just probably,
you know,
a very unusual dude.
So put it on a cassette tape.
Oh
my man.
Yeah.
All right.
Goes the bet awards comes
back with Rick Ross.
Look at Sandwich Ross.
And that is not the same expression he
has during those capitol one ads anger.
Oh yes,
he is eating shit right there.
He's like,
what?
Looking at Jamie.
Jamie Foxx looks high.
Okay.
Fuck.
That might've just been froze there,
but he looks high as fuck.
[inaudible] on the set that day.
Well,
what happened was,
is that
Batman a hundred black,
gray sweat can lady asked him,
I need a hundred black
preachers with a black sir.
Okay,
go over to carry with my little tape.
We're going to plant my own biome.
That's it.
The movie.
Any Hamilton,
we don't have beaten this guy.
One unfortunate incident.
It was a few fortunate,
isn't it?
A few of them out there this
and he's a beautiful director.
I'm happy he's alive.
I love his fucking movies.
I'll tell you that man.
That dude make some gangster movies.
His movies are fun as Shit.
If reservoir dogs,
if I'm flipping the
channels and reservoir dogs,
come on.
No,
you don't like on cable.
Just randomly.
I get very excited.
Yeah.
It's one of those classics we like.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
That's a God damn classic movie.
Yeah,
pulp fiction.
It's one of the best movies ever.
Totally.
I remember when I went to see it,
I was like,
this is I.
It was like,
it was so next level.
I left the theater.
I was shaking my head like this
motherfucker just broke movies.
He just figured out to make a movie
where you go back in time and forward in
time and you're following it all and
everyone's gets shot in the fucking head
and it's like,
whoa.
It was the greatest movie ever.
If I had to pick like one movies,
my favorite movie of all time,
I think pulp fiction would
be on a very short list.
Definitely.
Yeah,
so goddamn good.
It's nonstop.
I loved kill bills.
I love to kill bills.
He it don't,
don't just shit on that guy.
Man.
That's a great video though.
I made a few errors in his time.
You seen this video?
No.
Play it.
Go ahead.
Okay.
This is a him slapping a reporter.
How's it going?
What's going on here?
What's going on?
What's going on here,
but that down.
What's going on here?
What are you doing?
Teachers.
You need to talk to me just for,
just for the what are you doing it?
Log into that again.
Hit me.
She's not just a guy from right
now.
I can't do it.
Yeah.
So cool.
Cause you're filming.
But if that was off I'd be whooping
your ass up and down this tree.
Yeah.
Incident.
You know,
just walking around like
crazy quick.
He's in Russia.
Try to buy coffee.
It's a one of those film fest
is one of those.
What the fuck is that?
It's so weird.
It's one of those film festivals
that is in the freezing cold.
That is a weird way to approach it.
Dude.
Like Quentin Tarantino just stick
a fucking camera in his face.
Yeah,
nevermind.
Okay.
His coffee,
he's a dialogue driven guy.
So when that guy didn't answer his,
what are you filming?
You watched the switch and he goes,
what?
He goes from what is this?
And he's still normal to that guy
not answering and his eyes just,
he loses it.
Well there's also that weird moment when
like he's trying to play it cool when
the guys go on,
come on.
Go for it was like,
man,
I don't think,
cause you could feel the
tension between the two of them.
They just had a physical altercation,
altercation,
but he's still trying to like
maintain like social calmness.
It's very weird,
right?
Yeah.
Watching conflict is fucking weird.
It's always weird cause you can like
sense like how you would be in that
situation.
Oh Jesus Christ.
This is why people love drama.
They love like feeling it without
having to be a part of it.
You know that,
that's why people love movies
that are fucking crazy dramatic.
As long as they end happily,
people get like super bummed
when movies don't end right.
Because part of us,
when you're watching a movie,
you're somehow or another invested in
these people that you're following.
You know?
That's why when they get into conflict,
it's so exciting.
Even though you know it's bullshit.
But when you see real conflict like that,
there's something like
weirdly exciting about it,
right?
Yeah.
It is a sick drill.
It's awful.
It fucking makes you tingle.
A blizzard
after an argument,
but he helped you get out
of a fucking snow bank.
Do you ever seek death proof?
The one where Kurt
Russell plays a stunt man.
It's a serial killer with his stunt car.
No,
that's,
is that a term?
Yeah,
but what happened was grinder.
Yeah.
When they made the,
when they made the double feature,
Rodriguez is movie went first and
Terentino's when second and it's tough to
follow an hour and a half long Rodriguez
action movie and that's what happened.
And they put it out as a
modern day double feature,
but it's sort of buried this movie,
the Terantin oh maid,
you know,
and it's very Tarantino and very cool
and almost completely sort of unknown
about compared to his other movies.
Wow.
What's it called?
Death proof.
Kurt Russell.
See those movies?
Because I just like all your saw the
commercials for whatever reason or never
got around to seeing them.
Yeah.
It looks like it might be fun to watch,
but I don't know,
man.
I'm going to,
the movies can be so brutal.
Yeah.
You're risking people not talking.
You know,
you're risking it and it happens.
It happens every other time.
Every other time we go to the movie,
someone's just having a fucking converse
and the rappers and the popcorn.
I don't understand how popcorn
became the fucking movie thing.
It's the loudest food.
She'd be like Jello.
She'd be cello or milkshakes or something.
It's popcorn is just [inaudible] it's
true in the bag and everything about
popcorns loud popcorn is like Turkey.
Like how the fuck did it
become king of Thanksgiving,
right?
I mean is there any real evidence
those motherfuckers reading turkeys?
No.
Why is it this one food,
they may have been eating
popcorn for all we know.
Well they didn't.
Their corn was like goofy back then.
Yeah.
You know,
you ever see what old corn looks like?
Like non GMO corn.
It's one of the things that people like,
Ooh Jumo fuck goons scourge GMO.
If you look,
look at what GMO actually is.
Like not,
not just like changing the,
you know,
these plants so that they uh,
they can deal with
pesticides better and doing,
they do a lot of weird shit today.
That's like super scientific
gene splicing type shit.
But genetically modifying like
everything that we eat is like modified.
They've like selectively
bred everything that we eat.
Like corn used to be the scrappy little
fucking dainty thing and now it's these
big ass Iowa ears,
you know all those,
like our tomatoes,
all of our apples,
like all that stuff's been engineered.
You know,
it hasn't all been done in a lab,
but it's all been like we've,
they've made these crops like very in
a specific manner so that they have a
higher yield.
Did you ever see king corn now
everybody should see that movie.
It's a freak out.
[inaudible] was the best part in it.
When they should a big hole in the side
of a cow and they're just reaching in
there.
That's on,
that's in food inc to have
that food bank as well.
Like whenever they want to talk
about like feeding cattle grain,
they always show these
cows and have these open,
I don't know what exactly they're doing,
but they have these open hole.
Well,
you could literally reach into the
cow's stomach so they have a hole on the
outside of their body and you could reach
your hand into that hole and actually
pull the food out of this cow stomach.
Did they develop abscesses?
Sometimes from eating grains and eating
things that like their body just doesn't
want to process and then they're there.
They're pumping.
I'm filled with fucking antibiotics that
just jack and their system up and these
fucking house,
like if you,
if you watch this video and you see this,
this whole in the cow or like
you're looking into its stomach,
you're like,
what is wrong with people?
Like what are we doing?
Like what,
how do you,
how is this okay?
Like how is it okay to have
a hole in the cow side?
We could reach your hand
in and just like it's,
it's that fucked up that it's like
its stomach is outside of its body.
See if he could pull that up
just so we could see it from,
these guys haven't seen it.
And what does that do?
It,
it makes the,
they do it to treat the cows
because the cows start getting,
I think they do it for different reasons,
but I think one of the main ones is that
when these cows are eating grains and
they're,
they're getting sick,
they developed these abscesses
in their body and um,
I think that's what it is with Kelsey.
That's that.
That's where the cow's stomach is.
It looks like a joke or something.
Like a,
a photo shop.
Yeah.
It's,
but coins in around the edges.
I should know the whole
reason why they do it,
but it's one of the main reasons
why people are propublic.
He's got his hand in that guys.
Oh my goodness.
It's one of the main reasons why people
were like trying to go back to grass fed
beef.
Like if you have grass fed beef,
it's not going to be as juicy.
It's not going to be as fat.
It's not going to be like
when you cook a Ribeye,
like a corn fed rib eye.
Oh my goodness.
They're just crackling
with fat and it's just,
it's so good.
But that animal's sick.
Like it's not a healthy animal.
It's got that all that fat,
it's body.
What's going on?
It's,
it's this custody.
Oh,
when she's pulling the
matter out of the cow's body.
Yeah.
He said they were doing
it to help the cow.
I think in that situation,
when they have that out,
that ring on the outside of it and
they're reaching into the cow's stomach,
I think they'd do it
because the cows Foxville.
If they don't,
I don't understand it totally.
I shouldn't be talking about it,
but whatever it is is bad.
Fucking disgusting.
I was like,
can I just vomit this whole documentary?
King corn was all about corn and how
much corn is in our food and they go
through these,
these college kids that go through the
supermarket and just start pulling things
off the shelves and recognizing how
much of everything has corn in it.
And then they do this,
this test on their own body and their,
it found out their
bodies like mostly corn.
Like most of the carbon in their body
came from corn or whatever the fuck it
was.
But it's one of those things where you,
you know,
they take you,
yeah.
You can stick his hand in the
whole of the whole workout.
You son of a B Hinchcliffe yeah,
it's a,
I dunno,
it's,
it's a very
weird thing,
but you can just stick
your hand in to someone's,
some animal stomach like,
yeah.
It looks like a piggy bank
saying like the circle.
Yeah.
It's a piggy cow I think.
So point being that's no,
you know,
that's uh,
it's not good.
Not Great.
That corn shit's not good for cows.
Oh,
so how,
how many shows do you
guys got in the can now?
82 82 kill Tony.
So you girls have 82 minutes of comedy.
Does anybody ever called in sick?
No.
Damn fucking powerful workers.
Yeah.
You guys dedicated?
Not once.
No period talk.
No,
no,
no.
One time I was in a flight back home
and that was when we first started.
Yeah.
I was just back home and I missed one
and I even tried to record a set and send
it in.
I remember that.
Have you guys gone anywhere
else in the country?
Like other cities?
Um,
we've gone to San Diego
and we did pass it.
Dina,
did you guys do kill Tony in San
Diego or did you do stand up?
We didn't get downtown San Diego.
I know you did it in Pasadena.
Yeah,
comedy store.
La Jolla here.
That's the other thing that's
weird about doing comedy in La.
Like la has a kind of specific crowd
and a lot of ways and there's some shit
that you can do in La that literally
won't fly anywhere else in the flyover.
You know,
there's,
there's certain shit that you
can do here in this town like,
like it has a very certain
sensibility almost all towns do.
Like Boston was famous for
having a Boston sense of humor,
a lot of Boston related material
that didn't work anywhere else.
So like this,
one of the best things to do is
a go to as many different spots.
Do you guys find that it's very different?
The crowds he experienced the
comedy store versus the road?
Yeah,
I think,
I feel like it's harder here.
The crowds are harder in la because I
feel like everyone's just used to watching
entertainment all the time.
All the time and auditions and
like different shows and Improv.
So people are just used to
seeing other people try to,
you know,
work their craft.
Yeah.
Here when I went to Bray,
uh,
which isn't even that far,
I was like,
Whoa,
I need to get out of La Cause Bray is
not that far and I get there and I'm kind
of like dry and like they just like,
it was just like this weird disconnect.
And that was a moment where I was like,
wow,
I just got to keep going other places.
Yeah.
But you know,
here's the other difference.
There's people that come to a place,
like the comedy store and they're used
to seeing a lot of experimentation,
a lot of new material.
But when you're in a club like Braya,
like you got headliners
coming in every week.
I mean that's really what it's like.
The Bray improv headlines
coming every week.
And that's what those people say.
They go there,
they see this guy kill,
they see that God kill.
They see this girl kill.
And when you do that over
and over and over again,
you,
you sees in your crowd.
Like if you look at the lineup
of like the Improv and Brio,
it's just a murderer after murderer.
It's just a sterile assassins and
they're all coming in for the weekends.
So like you,
you have like this whole system there
where people were accustomed to a very
high level of like national level comedy.
Yeah.
I think it's easier.
This places a lot easier.
I agree.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
the thing about those places is they're
not as open to experimentation though.
Yeah.
Right.
And I was hosting the weekend.
I like knew what I was doing,
but it was such a good experience.
Cause that Friday I was like,
Whoa,
La has the more educated as
far as like comedy style,
like hack stuff doesn't go over in la the
way we'll go over in some places like,
but that's harder to do any more anyway.
Isn't it like hacks.
Dot.
Like you really,
it's all worn out.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't exist anymore.
Right?
Like,
where's the last guy that
you heard was a hack?
I just do an hack Joe's.
We see them every day.
I think.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
anybody who's on a lineup in front of me,
they mean if it's not like if they,
they,
you know,
they better be good or else I will.
I will complain about them being in front
of me on a lineup no matter how long
they've been to one
and no matter whatever.
You know what I mean?
It's just like if I hear a bad joke,
I just go,
why is this person have a better
spot than they made in fury?
Well,
you just made it really personal.
That's not what I'm [inaudible] about.
I'll call them a hack,
you know what I mean?
And not to their face.
You run into that though.
Do you see that?
I don't see that anymore.
I really don't see hacks any,
right?
Yeah.
I remember like they used to be
guys who had like a stock act,
right?
They had an act that was
just interchangeable with a
lot of other people's acts
and it was based on these like
really common premises like okay,
here's a perfect example.
A guy going to buy tampons for his wife
and he would get to the counter and the
thing wouldn't have a tag on it and
they would go price check tampons,
Aisle Alto.
There was a hundred guys who
did that joke and they're like,
please,
I'll pay you twice.
The money just don't do that.
Don't do that again.
How much is it?
I think it's $50 sir.
That's too much.
I saw so many people do that joke.
I mean it was one of those
things where it was like,
oh my God,
this is out of control.
There was like that premise.
It was like a super common hack premise.
Yeah,
cops and donuts.
That's where that came from.
It came from hacks.
Yeah.
When I hear the words guys
and girls are super different.
It listed be a totally let go.
Ironic about dating in La is hard.
Yeah.
The difference treat La and New York is
a lot of it is like,
you know,
you're just trying to think
of shit to talk about.
A lot of people when it's
like really based stuff,
it's a lot of the most
common stuff like travel,
most common,
you know,
differences between cities.
Like all that stuff is like,
like baby blocks like building
and sometimes still awesome.
Like someone doesn't
take it out of the mix.
Like if you had the most awesome the
difference between New York and La joke
today.
It's not like you can't
talk about that subject.
Like if you,
if you have it and it's funny I'll be
laughing like I'm not a comedy Snob at
all.
I think that people get silly with like,
you know what's acceptable,
what's not acceptable.
Like there's some dumb
shit that's really funny.
You know like it doesn't
have to all be smart like in,
it can be a stew of things like burn.
I were talking the other day about
pratfalls like he has this bit and he was
trying to figure out how to,
how to like almost get
like flipped on stage.
And I can't talk about it without
like sort of reveal on the premise.
So he and I were like,
I was showing him like these different
roles that you could do a different way.
You could fall where you're
not going to get hurt,
but it'll look kind of crazy.
Your legs be over the air.
And uh,
he was like,
we were talking about like,
Prat falls like pratfalls aren't cheap.
Right.
If it's,
I'm like,
if it's,
if it's a part of a joke and
it makes the joke better,
it's funny,
you know?
Yeah.
But there's some people who would back
off because they worried about the
contempt of their peers,
you know,
they worry about,
oh,
what are you doing?
Flips on stage now.
Tony Hinge also
comedian,
like I like,
you know,
somebody who moves around
and stuff like that.
If that's part of their natural thing,
then yeah,
they could do that.
But you know,
some people,
Joey Diaz,
one Joey moves around a lot,
but it keeps the mic and this,
I can't picture him doing Pratt off,
but he's done some,
some karate kicks on stage.
I've seen that really.
Yeah.
Joey gets crazy sometimes.
He,
but he always keeps the mic in the stand.
If you noticed that about Diaz,
he never holds the mic.
Ah.
He uses both of his hands and
it keeps the mic in the stand.
He's one of the few guys that do that.
Yeah,
he's got a totally different style,
you know,
but it works,
man.
It,
he's a master of having that
microphone in the stand.
Yeah.
I love what he does when he's killing.
He grabs it by its side and he looks,
it's straight up,
a few inches
down.
You just hear that the,
the,
the debate is on the monster.
He's got this new bit about Isis.
I was fucking,
tears were pouring down my eyes.
He was a red,
like a beat and screaming at the top of
his lungs and the water and sweat was
flying and he's taking his
jacket off while he's killing,
while he's,
Kelly used to take his jacket
off to in this isis bit.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he's the best.
He's the best ever.
Yeah.
You know,
if you,
if you never seen Joey Diaz live,
you don't understand.
There's another level and
he's a perfect example.
Like there's no like great
intellectual truths in his act.
It's shit that he thinks is fucking funny.
He's just tried to kill,
he's trying to say the funniest
shit that he could say.
Yeah.
And,
and in doing that,
like,
you know,
he hits this rare air
sometimes I'll like Joey Diaz,
his hit some air that uh,
I do.
I don't think this may be like three
or four other people I've ever seen hit
that level.
Like he,
there's a level of crying in the crowd
during some of his bits and people just
hitting tables because they can't breathe.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause this dude is just,
and he's fucking slaying.
It's Brett's coming out of his mouth.
That's one of the fun things about the
sitting in the back of a comedy room is
you get to see the shadows,
the people in front of you,
how they're physically moving
different than the rest of the show.
Rest of the show.
They're pretty still,
like you might see them pop
and down for laughs and stuff.
But if you're sitting in the
back during a Joey Diaz said,
it's like you see like spit
takes flying in the air.
One guy falling out of his seat
and other guys slamming a table.
And then another thing that Joey does
that I just love and I always look for is
that he kills faster
than anybody else too.
Like for some reason the
audience immediately can
tell he's just being himself
an artist or renal.
When he walks up there and goes,
hey,
cock suckers [inaudible] bar,
and it's already happening.
Right.
They connect with them immediately.
There's none of that.
Hey,
good to meet you.
Uh,
you know,
yeah,
no,
he's,
he's just funny to look at.
Yeah,
he's funny.
Everything's funny.
His personality is funny.
He's so unique,
like,
and how he talks,
he's just everything about him.
He,
this is a unusual dude and I'm glad
he's back at the comedy store too.
You know,
Joey came,
he started back a couple of
weeks before I did and uh,
he told me,
he said,
man,
he goes,
it really,
really changed my act.
He said it really,
it really got me fired up.
I got excited about comedy again.
He goes,
it really like made me
excited about just killing.
I just wanted to kill.
I was like,
well,
he goes,
it just gave me another
shot of inspiration,
you know?
Alright.
You know,
Thompson girl and I were talking
about this last night that,
um,
when you have a bunch of friends
that are like really into stand up,
like everybody's like really
into writing new shit,
really into performing a lot.
Like you get so energized by that.
It's like you're on this like comedy,
caffeine thing.
Yeah.
It's the way it's really like,
it's,
you know,
surround yourself with people
that like you can relate to,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's why the store is so important.
That's why it's like that.
It's this weird freaky hangout spot.
You know,
like last night we were in the green room,
Zach Galifianakis,
Ken,
John,
the doctor from over movies.
Ken was there.
Yes.
I fucking guys.
Awesome.
Um,
who else was there?
Jeff Ross is back there.
Um,
and,
and tell Whitney Cummings is back there.
We're all hanging out,
having a fucking blast,
just laughing and telling Brad Williams
is back there laughing and talking and
telling stories and it's just like
that kind of a an environment man.
It just gets you so fired up to do comedy.
I went on that stage last night running,
you know,
I just couldn't wait to get up there.
It's like there was so much shit.
It was all in the air in that place.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's something that I forgot about man.
I really did.
I forgot about it when I left the
store cause I was so angry at the
circumstances and everything.
But I think even so,
I think it got better while we were gone.
People were saying that it got better
around the time of podcasting for some
reason that they sort of coincided that
it was like about five years ago the
store really started picking up,
which is about when like,
uh,
this isn't that like how long Adam
Carolla has been doing podcasts?
Most,
most comics about five years ago.
Yeah.
And I think that a lot of comics,
when they started doing podcasts and
the Corolla showing other people's
podcasts,
people started hearing about comedy
and then realizing that a lot of these
people that are comics,
they're just fucking regular people
that just decided to do comedy.
Like how many people have you met
in your life when you're like,
dude,
listen to me.
You should be a comedian.
No one,
never did.
I see him.
I meet people all the time.
So your cert more cynical in me.
There's some chick that was hanging
out at the bar the other night.
She was whole,
various.
She was hilarious.
She was really funny.
I go,
what do you do?
You know,
she's,
which works in banking.
I go,
you should be a comedian.
You're really fucking funny.
And she's got this,
got this natural sense of
delivery and personality.
I'm like,
you really should do it.
Just go to an open mic night.
Just go and watch how bad everybody sucks.
You'll want to do it cause like open mic
nights are the craziest places ever it,
right.
If you want to find the epicenter of
Cuckoo in Hollywood or hacks or some hacks
at open mics.
Yeah,
they're hackers.
Mostly actors.
That's a good expression.
I hate that though.
You see that a lot,
especially on killed Tony.
These guys that don't
really want to be comics,
but they're doing it because
they want to be come an actor.
So they kind of go through that route.
It really,
it's really noticeable.
Yeah.
Or they want to brag to their improv
troupe that they went and did stand up at
the comedy store and then
they tell you I'm a comic.
Yeah.
Well not only can they do,
I'm proud,
but I'm also a comedian.
Yeah.
That would be like your,
your headshot standup comedian.
Actor,
first actor slash standup comedian.
Yeah.
There's some about actors that like,
it's really difficult to get
somebody to pick you for stuff.
Like it's the worst part
about being an actor.
Like I know people that are actors that
are like really struggling and they,
it's,
it's an insanely frustrating because
it's not something you can just do.
You know?
Like,
if you do stand up,
there's an open Mike night,
you go up,
you fucking kill and you,
if you just keep doing that,
eventually somehow or another you just
get better and you become a professional.
I mean that's really the,
the college of standup comedy.
But for an actor,
you've got to have somebody find you.
You've got to have somebody fine,
dude,
they've got to come get you.
They got to see you.
You do the audition,
they go,
that guy,
let's make him the guy and they take in,
they fucking put makeup on you and
they push in front of the camera,
give you a bunch of shit
to say and they picked you.
But guess what?
He could have done it.
They could change the gender.
She could have done it.
I mean it's like there's so
many people for each role.
You know,
there's a few really good ones.
There's a few,
you know,
Marlon Brando type characters
that rise through the rest.
But the reality is
you've got to get picked.
And so this is weird social
game that's going on.
So they're,
they're all socially like terrified.
They're afraid and not all of them,
but a lot of them,
they're afraid to truly speak their mind.
They're always like in this weird like
confi they're always like hoping that you
liked them because they have the audition
all the time and these powerful people
standing in front of them and go,
hmm,
I don't know.
Like Dom Irrera was telling me about
an audition then he went on and how
insulting it was.
The woman's started eating her sandwich
and checking her texts while he was
doing,
as long as she's eating a
sandwich and checking your texts,
I was like,
Whoa,
that's dark.
Yeah.
That's rough.
And if,
if that's how you make your living and
you keep going to these things and some
woman's they're eating or
sandwich or some guy is a,
he's a in the middle of a text
message while he's listening to you.
Thanks.
Thanks Tony.
That was very good time.
We'll be in touch and you're like,
oh my God,
I'll never eat.
You mean that's fucked.
Yeah.
And sometimes like commercial auditions,
they'll just want like a reaction
and then people are like,
oh,
how was it?
They're like,
I don't know,
I just like smile,
but I don't know how I did.
Yeah,
yeah.
Commercial auditions for the worst.
When I first started,
I got sent on a lot of those
and the assistant for the
agent that I had was like
the worst.
He was notoriously bad at what he did
because there were a few guys signed with
this agency at the store,
so he would just be hung over
from a crazy night before.
And he would send you
out on a bad audition,
like one that you're not even matched for,
who says we have an
audition for you today at,
you know,
33 sunset boulevard at 8:00 AM.
See,
get their schedule around it.
You get excited for it.
And then you show up and it's for,
you know,
50 year old Asian woman and you're
sitting there in a lobby with 50 year old
Asian women and then the guy,
it's finally your turn and the guy goes,
you know,
uh,
this isn't for you.
And I go,
but they told me to come
here and be here for this.
And you go,
well I guess we could get you in here.
It's like,
I ain't never had that.
When you do that,
would you play a 50 year old Asian woman?
Well,
no,
I would just read it
so tired.
I started acting like on,
um,
when I was living in New York,
I started going on audition
so it didn't do any acting,
but I got this agent and then
all of a sudden they'd go,
do you want to act?
And um,
and it was really one of those like,
okay.
And then also,
and I'm going out on auditions,
zero acting experience,
none.
Right.
And I was like,
what am I doing?
Like what is this?
And it was the first time I ever got to
see child stars because I didn't know
about that.
I had no idea that there was these
like stage moms in the stage,
moms with their kids,
especially for like a
commercial auditions.
Do you guys run into them in la?
I'd sage moms.
I've seen some,
yeah,
I have it.
I'm like,
they're the scariest,
and I grew up here,
so I saw a lot of stage moms when I was
like little like in school there's like
act or kids with their stage moms
and my mom was afraid of them,
so now I'm just,
I've always avoided,
but I've seen a mom out of a
commercial audition who said to her,
kid,
sit down or I'm going to
beat the Jesus out to you.
Like in the commercial audition,
like,
yeah,
okay.
Jesus.
Yeah,
expressions.
It's like,
Wah,
hit my kid but I'm not
going to blast him the Lord.
It's the budget,
but I don't say the real Jesus.
Jesus is the fake cheese
from the creator of the name.
The word licorice whips
comes beejesus licorice.
It seems like the
same guy who made that word probably
made up beejesus licorice whips be Jesus.
Maybe bell licorice whips.
Real licorice.
Black people.
That's hilarious.
But Jesus,
oh,
that sounds like something that Taryn,
Tina would say while
promoting on the beach,
I cannot figure it out.
My computer.
I just always felt like the culture of
a auditioning was always like insanely
like defeating and get felt bad.
Like,
and I used to think that like that's the
reason why I think a lot of people are
depressed in Hollywood.
Like especially actors.
Like when I started going on auditions,
I f I failed miserably and
all these movie auditions,
I went on it because they'll,
your agency will send you
out for shit that like,
like say if they already have
some movie star for a role,
they already have it cast.
They'll still take like
30 people and they'll say,
well you should,
you should go so they can see you because
they might like it for something else.
And I'd be like,
what?
Like in my mind I was like,
this doesn't even make any sense.
It's like you want me to act?
So you want me to learn some lines and
go and make a relationship with a casting
director.
Okay,
I get it.
I guess I get it,
but I didn't get it at all.
So I would go there and I would
always feel bad after I leave.
I be like,
this is just,
I had a,
one time I went to this audition,
it was one of the most
embarrassing moments ever.
I went into his audition and this lady
was reading the audition and she was
asking me where I was
from and I said that,
uh,
I'm from,
just moved from New York.
I said,
but,
uh,
I was,
born in New Jersey and she said,
I'm born in New Jersey too,
but I don't tell anybody that.
I tell them I'm from New York.
I go,
why?
Why wouldn't you just tell them
that you're from New Jersey?
And she goes,
because,
oh,
nobody wants to be from New Jersey.
So I just tell them I'm
from New York and I go,
that seems ridiculous.
She goes,
okay,
do you want to read this?
I go,
all right.
So I start reading it and she's given me
these like fucking dead eyes because I
insulted her need to be from New York.
I'm mocked her.
I mean,
it was like the most,
I was like,
I was just talking to a person,
like if you said that
to me and I'd be like,
ah,
yeah,
why the fuck do I lie?
Why do I tell everybody I'm from New York?
Does that make me better than
if I was from New Jersey?
Like I my that ridiculous.
Instead of being proud
to be from New Jersey,
so in this I have to sing to this chick,
so I have to,
I have to do these stupid lines.
Like I'm literally like,
it's like a country western song.
I'm lake side with a girl and we have
like a blanket laid out and I have to sing
a Bruce Springsteen song
to her and I died that day,
shine in front of her.
Like I felt my soul leaving my body as
I'm like trying to soulfully sing this
Bruce Springsteen song,
this woman who's looking at me like
I'm just a steaming sack of shit in her
office and then when I'm done,
she was,
thanks.
Did you try to save it at the end?
Like thank you again.
I'm Joe Rogan from New York.
No,
I know it was death.
That would be funny.
No,
it was dead,
but I had to go through with it
anyway and I went through with it.
I was like,
oh my God,
a man.
Now imagine if your check and he'd go
into an audition and the dude tries to
fuck you.
Right.
Or you know,
sexually harass you in some strange way.
Mr Hinchcliffe.
Yeah,
I know.
I imagine that could happen with you as
well under the right circumstances with
a very aggressive gay man.
Oh it ha.
It could have happened.
It could have.
It could have,
but you what?
You'd be you I,
when I get out of the room I don't
make direct eye contact with anybody.
Kept your mouth shut.
When I was auditioning
for album,
I got far along in the audition process
for book of Mormon at one point,
which is like a big Broadway production.
I got in the middle of it,
kept doing good.
Got It.
Just kept moving on.
You should have seen the lobby for that.
My friend,
a bunch of little twinks
trying to be Mormons or like,
you know,
musical theater.
You know what that means,
right?
Right.
Do they do that thing with the,
with the butts and the wieners?
Did you see there was an article,
I think it was like Huffington post or
one of these recently about this upsurge
in Mormon porn.
Yeah.
And that there's like Mormon
porn sites now to help every,
every,
everyone starts with a
boy knocking on the door.
You're all like Mormon,
Mormon,
cam girls and,
and things along those lines.
And there's Mormon,
Mormon missionary,
gay sex porn bicycle
from three bang bice.
Yeah.
More than before.
And here it is.
There's,
there's no bullshit.
well,
there's a,
there's this,
I don't know if this is a,
we don't know if that's,
that's not the one that I
was looking at the article.
The article was about this guy.
What does that make you?
The special effects?
These Mormons guy.
The old cheese.
Yeah.
So these,
um,
this one guy was telling you
about his experience in camp,
you know,
with,
uh,
some other,
like he realized he was gay when he was
gone to these Mormon camps with guys and
he was attracted to him and just
took the right guy to make it happen.
And that's why he did,
you know,
he had such an exciting experience.
Now he's married with children.
He's not gay,
but wow.
So this is the story.
So he decided to make a Mormon.
You have to click.
Are you over 18,
Brian?
Click mentally.
Brian,
you have to say now,
what would you say?
Like mentally you are like,
it's 14 your maturity levels,
but 18,
18 intelligence still like Gi joes.
So yeah.
1818.
That was it.
That's what makes an eight team.
Sarah,
how old are you mentally?
Yes.
Um,
it depends.
Either I'm like 65 or 12.
Yeah,
that's a good answer.
That's it.
Like,
so when you're tired,
you're 65.
Yeah.
Or having a good time or 12 or 12 like,
yeah,
I feel like I'm like just my age mentally.
I don't know.
In the moment chick.
I'm 109 how'd that happen?
It's paid too much attention to shit,
dude here I think so.
You've taken too many variables.
I probably do.
Yeah.
Well you're a,
you're a bit obsessed.
Tony Hinchcliffe could a bit
obsessed with the standup comedy
with everything today.
I thought I was dying
in the shower for sure.
I was 100% positive that I
was having an appendix attack.
Like something like right in my,
in my upper,
I mean lower belly and I'm just like,
this is that this is,
I can convince myself that the worst
shit is happening and then what to,
yeah.
I mean I've been on the road with
him and it's happened a few times.
Right.
So you're essentially a hypochondriac.
Does that what it is?
It's more of a panic attack type of thing,
but it's like not like
what you think a panic.
It's just all inside the head.
Oh.
And anyway,
ended up fighting and then the
appendix attack was gone that fast.
It was just one little
fourth second tutor.
Rooney.
I have had that happen.
I've had that happen before.
You get a weird stomach pain,
you're like,
what the fuck is that like that's new.
Yeah.
And when it's new,
immediately my Amy,
I'm sure you guys got to be the same
where it's like I've never felt that
before.
And that's gotta be something
or just farts or what were you
eating all that Vegan food do?
That's a problem.
It always ends up being a fart
by the way was my problems.
Broccoli shit gets impacted.
I had,
I need to put a hole in my stomach's
that people can pull out the grains.
Too many grains.
I think that's essentially like
diverticulitis probably in a lot of ways.
That's what happens to a,
that's what happened at Brock Lesnar.
Yeah.
It happened to a few people.
I know they had to get uh,
parts of their colon removed.
Oh yeah.
One guy know,
caught it before it got too bad,
but you just get impacted.
And uh,
Anthony Bordain was telling me that it
can be anything he said he could like be
like a pumpkin seed or
something gets stuck in there.
Like he eats something,
gets stuck and then it creates an abscess.
Is like,
it's not just meet like with Brock Lesnar,
supposedly it was just,
he all he ate was meat.
Like it wasn't eating any fiber and his
bowels get all fucked up because of it.
Yeah.
Whoa,
wow.
Yeah.
You got to eat.
Like you have to eat healthy,
you know,
like fiber's important for your body.
It's not,
it's not just a luxury,
it's a necessity.
Like if you want this thing to work right,
you gotta eat lettuce,
it's got a push everything out.
Yeah.
And when you don't,
it can really,
and then there's some people that get
it to just have a propensity for it
apparently.
But when they,
when they have to remove like
sections of your intestines and Shit,
Oh God,
clean my bedroom the other day
and I have a pretty big bed.
But underneath bed
it's like in the middle,
you never can get anything on,
you know,
like if something falls under the bed.
So I was trying to get everything and
I pulled out a single cheeseburger from
Mcdonald's that I guess
I was eating and I threw,
I threw it on the ground or something.
And it just went in there
and get like to you,
I know budget,
how can you live?
Like I haven't had mcdonalds in my bed
for at least six months and so that,
but when I opened it,
it looked brand new.
It looked just exactly the same.
You would buy that perfect apartments
like the raft of a survivor stranded at
sea.
It's just scattered disarray with
bobbers and nets and one shoe
pirate in the corner for some reason.
Yeah,
that big area in the middle we can't
reach under your bed area is a problem.
It's disgusting it.
Cause if you ever do move,
you bed your bed,
you're like looking at it going,
that's so gross.
How much would I have
to pay you to lick that?
The center area we can't reach.
Just do the whole line.
All the line up from the head to the
keep your tongue down on the ground from
the foot of the bed to
the head of the bed.
Like an Imac.
It would only take an imac
to get you to do that.
Hell yeah.
Wow.
What about Ipad mini?
I licked,
I licked the stripper pole.
I licked the stripper pole at a crazy
girl as a couple of months ago on stage.
We were doing comedy there.
Uh,
and I just said some hot girl
just got off and I was like,
damn,
that girl is hot.
And I just like licked it as a joke.
Everyone was like,
but then I thought about it and then I
had like a canker on my time for like
three days.
Yeah.
Welcome to the wonderful
world of new age canker.
I was freaked out for a couple
of days but it was so hilarious.
That is so hilarious.
David Arquette owns that place
now and I told him like he would,
he did kill Tony and I told him about
that and you just give me a high five.
He's like that's great.
That's hilarious.
He owns a strip club.
And what a good mood for a fucking
celebrity that's just getting divorced.
What an excellent move.
And that place is a,
they do comedy occasionally there.
Yeah they do shows art
like music sometimes.
And she calmed me that it's totally
not set up for comedy though.
Cause they have like a strobe
light facing the comic.
So you're onstage and you're just having
elliptic Caesar's and you can't see
anything.
Whatever that is.
It click elliptical seizures,
epileptic.
He Fuck [inaudible] lip ellipses.
That sounds uh,
that sounds terrible.
Yeah.
And uh,
it's,
it's a,
the ceiling cuts down so it's like chops
the top part of your head off so they
can't even see you.
Oh,
part of your head.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We'll just do your comedy on your knees.
Lifted you comedy like as a
like to like a dancer's routine.
Do your comedy,
like don't even like talk about the fact
that got your leg wrapped around the
pole when you're going around in circles,
talking about your day
doing stupid style.
There's a lot of those cool little spots
in Hollywood though that aren't what
you think they are.
You know,
it looks like it would be like,
it's like kind of a hangout.
Aren't you doing a the spot tonight or the
Watkins?
Yeah,
that's a little,
where's it at?
What's it called?
Three of three o'clock.
A cool little realm.
It really,
really is.
I,
it's a,
it's just like this,
it's like a cool hip bar.
Um,
and then you go through these double
doors and it's a cool showroom.
One of my favorite little show
rooms and all of Hollywood.
Nice.
Yeah,
it's really neat.
Yeah.
And he's doing one of those
like Thunderpussy style
shows that people yell out
topics and you discussed them.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Should be fun.
Well,
fund your post.
He's a really fun show to do it too.
And if you have the right
crowd and it's right.
Exactly.
And this show,
because it's in Hollywood,
so the audience is a little more open
than a Pasadena crowd who's a little bit
more outside.
So the crowds are always a little
bit better for this than for,
you know,
the passenger,
I mean,
not good.
They're not necessarily a better crowd.
There were more interactive crowd to
give you the topics that you need,
like a better,
like a better group of suggestion.
Right,
exactly.
A little bit wide open with suggestions.
Yeah.
You can't get a better
crowd than the ice house.
Literally don't think it's possible.
Exactly.
What only was possible.
They're so good and like everybody,
they're so nice too.
It's just like the whole like
storm of coolness there last night.
It was so much fucking fun,
man.
Yeah.
That's a great audience.
It was pretty powerful.
That was amazing last night.
Yeah.
Good God.
Damn time Tommy should grow.
It was killing me.
Oh my God.
He's funny.
Thompson Gora is a god
damn monster right now.
He's just getting funnier all the time.
Just all the time.
It's constantly working at it.
Ian Edwards to slayed it.
Slided last night.
Have you seen bill burns and
new special now go get it.
Really?
It's amazing.
It's really good.
It's really fun.
It's like like actual bill bar,
like doing a set.
It doesn't seem like you're
doing a special at all.
I like sometimes you've seen people do
specials and they look like a little more
tense than they do when they're,
you know,
they're just doing a set burden.
Nailed it.
It's totally him.
It's awesome.
It's like black and white,
right?
Yeah.
I just wanted to do a black and white.
He said he's decided that
like everything's to HD.
It's like everything's like,
you know,
so much focus on high resolution and
looking at things like he just decided to
go old school to a black and white.
The jokes.
How long before you guys
decide to put something out?
I want to make sure it's really,
really good before I do,
I'm still so new.
Right?
Yeah.
I'm just scared to do anything too early.
Everyone keeps telling me to take my time.
Do you have a timeline?
I want to not be working a
day job within the next year.
To him that's ambitious.
So like two years in a comedy.
No Day job.
Maybe two and a half years.
That's ambitious as fuck.
Yeah.
I want it to,
I mean,
just doing enough to just like survive.
Obviously not being like touring and,
right.
Right,
Just like not working a day job.
Yeah.
And stuff like that.
It's hard.
How long before you quit your job?
MMM,
I was,
well,
I got a job working at the comedy store,
so I went solo just with that.
Yeah,
for,
yeah,
for
four years.
Just made enough money
to get by working there.
He at just just barely enough money to
get by because back then wasn't the same
exact regime of managers.
Right.
And what was happening before
where they were notorious for um,
for shaving hours that
you'd actually work.
And back then there were
also was literally one fifth
as many employees as there
is now.
So I was one of like five guys that was
working phones during the day and then
working the door at night.
So I was struggling.
Wow.
I wasn't even getting what I was working.
Those stories are so cool though.
When someone goes from being a doorman,
like Ari goes from being a doorman at
the comedy store doing his comedy central
special at the comedy store.
[inaudible] you know,
and then the name of it he liked,
he made it paid regular.
That was the name.
Cause like that was always the thing.
Like he wanted to become a paid regular.
Do you worked at it for like four and a
half years before she finally got him in
[inaudible]
but it's,
that's such a great story.
Like going from a guy just with an idea
in his head who started doing open mics
and from there become a
professional comedian.
I mean working the door,
worked in the cover booth,
doing all that shit,
answering phones,
doing all the shit the comics do.
Like that's one of the few places in the
country where comics go from just being
employees of the club to
like national headliners.
Yeah.
Same thing with rand is easy.
Yes.
It was just finishing
up when I was arriving.
Like he wasn't working there anymore.
But you heard that he would
talk about working there?
Yes.
Like I met him,
he worked there and now
I know as a TV star.
Yeah.
I would come by to do sets.
I think when I was on news radio or
maybe it might've been fear factor.
I don't know which one it
was when I first met him.
Hold on.
When Brenda's easy start.
I'm not sure.
Oh,
I know exactly when.
Actually,
it was November of 2011 because he was in,
he was in one of the towers when the
plane set on September 11th and he's like,
fuck it.
Well,
no,
no.
That's not what he started
doing comedy right after that?
No,
because he was in the Carlos Mencia
video and that was 2007 I think you mean
2001 is when timber 11 to Hollywood.
September 11 2001 yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
You said 2011 oh,
okay.
Yeah.
You said that timber 11 yeah.
Gotcha.
I know,
I forget.
It's hard to believe at nine
11 was 13 almost 14 years.
Wow.
That's weird.
Right?
That's crazy.
Do you think time is moving faster?
Yes.
Oh my God.
Perfect dancer.
That was probing stoner talk.
Oh my God,
yes.
Followed by a long run on sentence
where I throw in a bunch of likes,
so like I was like,
maybe like time is like different
me.
I was freaking out about
the Berenstain bears,
the spelling of the last name.
Yeah,
it's different.
It's different and it
wasn't always like that.
It's always been like that
and it's stain.
Wait,
wait,
what is it?
What do they call it in the Matrix?
In the matrix
spelled like stain
stain,
but I swear it was
Berenstein I've been cost.
Most people don't know what the fuck
we're talking about.
A series of children's children's books.
I said barren Steen and someone corrected
me and then I looked at it and I was
like,
oh yeah,
Ooh.
Like why did I think it said steam?
It was like I didn't
continue the sentence.
I got to Barron's and
there's an end of the end.
I'm like steam.
It must be seen.
Like I didn't,
I didn't even like attempt to read it.
Like I realize like sometimes words are
so similar to other words that you don't
really read them.
You kind of know,
oh I know what that is,
but you don't go and you just,
oh,
Barron's dean,
you know Wolfowitz if you saw like
Wolfowitz but like one of the letters was
different,
you'd still probably say
Wolfowitz cause you put it in.
I go and I've seen that before
and he just looked to save time.
You know,
you,
you say it.
So for all of us that thought,
I mean it was just one of those things
like you never really read the word.
Did you pull it up
Congress if though right?
Isn't that what we did?
We talk about this curse too much.
It's just show these,
well I bet show that ease people at home.
What the fuck we're talking about.
I thought it was a neat too,
so I bet it's one of those curse
a phase that looks like and
I don't think it is man.
I think it's just the way
it's a straight up stain.
Something happens.
Something happens,
seriously convinced for so long.
I went like three days just like
looking like a crazy person.
Bernstein bears.
No,
it doesn't.
It looks like that a should be an e.
But I think it's one of those things you
just sort of chunk those words together
that lettered the,
all those letters in your memory.
I remember that there was a ais.
I think that,
uh,
I think it's one of
those things you don't,
you just don't read it.
If everyone was already
fuck,
name his last name.
I don't know.
So stupid in this Dane.
You good say what's wrong
with Barrett's thing?
That's silly.
Bernstein is just as ridiculous.
Well,
I thought it was
Berenstain the whole time.
It must be one of those tracks where it
was like you see two e's before and then
you think the third one's
gotta be an easier thing.
It's like pop and soda.
I think that just where
you're like your mom,
your parents where it's like,
yeah.
Marin's stain.
Oh well that would make sense.
Berenstein Berenstain and you'd say dean.
Yeah.
What'd I say?
Getting to be more and more.
He'll bill t e I n it strictly,
what's the name of those Jew?
Bayer's
Barron.
Yeah.
It's like you ever wonder like why
certain languages came up with certain,
sounds like some languages have
beautiful flowing melodic sounds to them.
Like they have like a rhythm to them.
Like if you ever heard
someone speaking Portuguese,
like the Brazilians
that speaks Portuguese,
it's such a cool sound language,
Blah bishop.
Whether they have this like sort of like
almost like they're dancing like this
flow to it and then you'll hear like,
like some like really harsh German
[inaudible] Bush didn't like really like,
yeah,
it's like this weird sort of like guttural
and then like you know some of the
Sephardic languages and it's,
yeah,
it's some crazy ass noises.
You know Canadians a,
Oh that's about as normal as you get.
Add a little a to some words about it.
They're just a little far up north.
They're all too,
don't be picking out Canadian.
The bear chosen people
as far as I'm concerned.
The Berenstain bears had this one book
called new neighbors and I always thought
it seemed racist because it was like
Asian panda bears that moved in and look
how angry the dad is.
He's like Asians moving
in next door and bears,
oh that's hilarious.
They went with pandas madness
looking good damn weirdos building in
moves it build their Chinese restaurant
where neighbors
who have an oriental rug,
it's hilarious.
They're even wearing
kind of like colorful,
festive Chinese colors.
Those are definitely Chinese outfits.
Like look at how it's cut.
And it's like the shirts go
all the way up to the chin.
Fucking panda bears all wearing the same.
If somebody tried to release that today,
like salon.com would be all over it.
Yeah.
Subtle racism and children's stories.
Why it's wrong.
Yeah.
Finding racist.
But I think that is exactly what that was.
I mean,
that's not clever.
They're not hiding that panda.
But why isn't it black pairs?
You guys are Brown.
Have some black bears move in.
No.
Too Edgy
against black people.
Exactly.
So they had to go with pandas.
Is Asians fucking,
they keep their eye on their business
and they fucking keep moving forward.
They don't riot.
Asian people don't close off the fucking
four oh five they're nice and they get
things done.
Okay.
They don't get caught up in bullshit.
But if you,
if you use black bears,
boy,
dark skin,
light skin did bears versus dark skin.
But polar bears come in
and fuck up everything.
They've chose.
Black and white ethnically ambiguous
skin.
Yes.
That's crazy.
Their hair.
It's clear.
It's not actually white.
Yeah.
See if he could pull up a
picture of polar bear skin.
Polar bear hair.
Clear polar bear hair clear.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's like a,
almost like,
you know those fibers that
they use those light fibers.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The fiber optics,
like that kind of shit.
I mean that's what it looks like almost.
It's like a,
a natural white,
but it's like a natural clear rather.
But altogether they look white.
Well,
is there a bald,
is there a picture of like a bald skin,
but see if you could pull up a polar bear.
Heres a ball.
Polar bear.
I don't think they don't live.
Like some bears get
mange and they survive,
but polar bears live
exclusively in polar habitat.
That's what their hair looks like.
That's not a good picture.
But you get a sense of it.
It's,
it's more clear that it
does look pretty white,
but apparently it's
clear like technically,
so there's just a
complete absence of color.
So then they take all those together
and they look white when they're on the
animal.
Yeah,
I mean it is white.
Obviously it's white,
but they think they consider it clear,
so our brain reads it as white
Berenstain bears these days.
Awful to grow up with
these racist parents writing
these polar bear bucks.
Imagine what kind of Shit life you
must've led to come back as a polar bear.
What a Dick.
Can you say that you say that
you don't want to live up there?
It sounds like a lonely world.
You can always come back as like a magnet
that would suck worse.
Someone has the glass half full.
Yeah,
but being a polar bear
would be especially sucky.
Yeah.
Freezing cold,
jumping in the water all the time.
All you're eating is like seals,
shit and drinking coca cola.
What would you do for a Klondike Bar?
I think you could be fun.
There could be some
positives like name them,
like sliding around on the ice.
You can do that.
You can do that and you're a
person throwing up bear party.
They'd get more hurt as a person.
You would get more hurt sliding around.
You'd be less durable.
Yeah,
like just the thought of sliding
around on my polar bear belly.
That would be super fun.
Oh,
you ever did the,
uh,
the slip and slide?
Oh yeah.
Done it.
Yeah.
Well,
I haven't done it in quite some time,
but yes,
I've done it.
It's a child's game actually.
Get everyone's done it right.
It has never been done.
Slipping side.
That's not something you like trying
to shock them with your knowledge thing
that I did when I was young.
There's an adult one that they are,
they're trying to actually put a,
it's called slide the city.
Uh,
and there actually where you,
it's adult slipped inside throughout
the whole entire city of Los Angeles.
They got a water slide in Brazil
where you go like 55 miles an hour.
That's awesome.
The fastest water slide.
See if you could pull up the
fastest waterslide Brazil.
That's a giant slip and slide.
That's hilarious.
The whole city of Los Angeles.
So you slide through the
whole city and one push.
No,
I think it's the water moves you a little,
but oh,
and we all can't shower for a week.
You gotta be careful about waterparks.
I know a chick whose daughter got sick
from a waterpark and she want to be in
partially paralyzed.
She had some sort of infection getting
into her ear and it became like
meningitis or something like that.
Waterparks can get nasty man.
All these little kids are shit in that
water and all these weird people are
traveling around in their diseases.
It's just a breeding ground for bacteria.
That's why when you go to a lot of them,
they just reek of chemicals to just
pour in fucking coring and that water to
kill everything and you
get in and you're like,
Whoa,
like I'm bathing in chemicals here.
This doesn't even feel like water.
You know?
And it's kind of warm too.
There's a bunch of people in the water
and warm water and everyone's just pissed
and
can see like the sunblock splotches.
They should do like they should take like
a scoop and bring it to a lab and find
out exactly how much of that
water is pissed and shit.
It's like a measurable amount.
I'll admit I do it
get the worse.
They just have this thing
at the admit you do it.
Yeah.
If I'm in in that like a waterpark.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
It's like when in Rome.
I mean it feels good for the p around.
It's warm.
You're trying to be silly or do you
really pay when you go to a waterpark?
Yeah,
I think he does.
I don't even think he's in
the pool when he does it.
I think he's standing outside
of the pool and do it.
He's the guy which is pissing his pants.
Jumps in the water,
wait till a kid swim spa.
Wait,
Kid Swims by and you pee on kids.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
it's like blowing a fighter on a kid.
That's hilarious.
Have you ever heard her on a kid?
There's a big difference being blown
apart on a kid and pissing on him.
Okay.
And your parents,
kids.
Parents might be upset
if you fart on their kid,
they'll beat your ass
if you're peeing on him,
but they can never tell.
It's the only Legal Way to pee on a kid.
What do you mean they can never tell them?
They will never know if I pee on the kid.
Is it illegal?
Appear on here.
It definitely is a legal to PR on a kid
unless you're in a Kelly doesn't seem to
think it is.
Well,
he was his,
it wasn't just being charged with peeing
on the girls being charged with having
sex with an underage girl I guess.
Right?
Yeah.
I think it would have been okay at even
at a water park that according to Brian,
she called it pee pee.
Totally count.
So she didn't say Piss your honor.
Motion to dismiss.
The girl said Pp.
Mr. Kelly said Piss.
So clearly we're talking
about two different things.
One of them is
more cultural significance attached to it.
This is a strange time for race relations,
isn't it?
If you noticed,
this is a very tense time in
America for race relations,
black storm trooper to equal at all
out though is they're going to help.
I don't know,
but there are bad guys,
stormtroopers or bad guy.
I think he's a good guy that is
playing a bad guy for a second.
Then preview that we saw
stole a costume and he's like,
Oh,
don't say this.
Spoiler alert.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
No one,
no one knows that.
That's just a guess.
Oh,
okay.
You're back.
All right.
I thought you were giving
up the secret nerd info.
Have you been following this Sony leak
of all the crazy stuff that's been coming
out from the hackers
that have hacked Sony.
So a bunch of hackers have hacked Sony
and they like locked stony office is
down.
They stole movies that haven't been
released and I've been torrenting them.
They're releasing their private emails
of like how much like like does it,
there's this one real,
real well known producer.
They're just trashing Angelina Jolie's.
Like I don't care about this bid sheet,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah Blah.
And they're releasing all this.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
like all this budget info.
Like,
like there's the new Seth Rogen movie
that's a with James Franco and it's
showing how much more he gets paid.
Then James Franco,
Seth Rogan,
and it's just dirty shit.
And they're just,
it's just like all the other like leaks.
They've been slowly leaking it.
And releasing new stuff
that's just fucked up now.
What do you think they're
trying to do there?
When you're there,
you think they're trying
to shut down Sony.
Do you think they're
trying to just have fun?
I uh,
I don't know that cause they don't
really know for sure who's doing it.
At first they thought it was
North Korea because of that.
Oh,
that's right.
Cause that new movie,
I honestly think it's
just angry Asians that uh,
because of that movie,
they have no connection with North Korea.
But God,
you're here to give your doctor
Brian fucking work done whatsoever.
I to the,
and I'm just saying when
I say stuff like that,
it's like if I had to guess,
but doesn't the,
the North Korea thing makes sense,
right?
I mean,
especially if they're released it and
change Franco and Seth Rogen information
when they were on that movie together,
that was about assassinating
the president of North Korea.
Right,
right.
You know,
they have hackers working for them.
They must.
Yeah.
But there was a whole article about it,
which they're not really
good at much there.
Like they build,
they build rockets that just
like fall over when they hit,
you know,
launch your taunting them.
They,
they're now listening to Tame Creek.
Isn't that the one place
where they don't listen?
You say that about how the fuck did
they find out about this James Franco,
obviously they're paying attention.
No,
they were pissed at
that was being released,
right?
Yeah.
I would have said no to that movie.
I would have said,
ah,
you know,
they kill people for real over there.
Like this shit is in a movie.
Like
that fucking guy is essentially like one
of the last real old school dictators
on the planet who runs an empire and
you ask people under his iron fist,
I mean he's running that country and
his dad was running that country.
He just got it from his dad.
I mean that you don't
want to fuck with that.
Right the way you want.
If you want to fuck with that.
Only with like peace talks or a war.
Like those are the only two.
Like you don't want to like mock them.
Yeah.
Do you James Franco?
It's fine.
It's James Franco.
James Franco.
I know that's how we think.
If they showed up at Jane Franco's house,
fucking cut his throat and hung him by
his ankles and you know out the second
story window and you'd be like,
oh,
okay,
those are,
these are people like it doesn't,
they don't give a fuck
if you are an actor.
Like they don't care.
They don't care if you're famous.
They're famous too,
you know?
But they're famous for that.
The kid is famous for
like killing his uncle.
He killed like his uncle and his uncle's
family and his children and then gave
his wife a promotion,
like killed their kids and
gave the wife a promotion.
Like she's done like
some gangster shit man.
It sounds like a game of Thrones
episode duty actually do in North Korea.
What did that say?
What did you say?
It's getting really dirty.
The lashes out at Sony,
exact four horse snipe.
I protect my
brand.
It's getting really dirty because like,
I mean everyone that's Sony has worked
with like there's information going out
so it's getting like actors are now
fighting back and Sony's having to release
all these like,
apologies.
I mean it's getting every email.
Oh they said nasty shit.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
cause it's,
imagine you know the how managers
are in Hollywood or you know,
just Hollywood people,
how they talk back and forth.
You know,
we could buy that person,
fuck this person,
they suck and all that shit.
Did someone call Kevin Hart a
whore or is that what happened?
Who called Kevin Hart a whore.
The biggest in an email.
Yeah.
And
I protect my brand that guys,
he's smart.
That's what he is stupid.
Just making money.
Kevin Hart is smart as fuck.
He's working hard.
Yeah.
Plus he's like Super Nice.
You know,
how do you call that guy a whore?
Yeah,
I saw him,
uh,
organically battle Tony Rock and in big
the urban show that they have at the
comedy store,
the big trip and on Tuesdays or whatever,
just organically
started,
sold out main room and they were
laying into each other one night.
I remember being with
a bunch of Comedians,
like one of those ones where
you're holding on to shit,
you know,
they're the best at it.
And Kevin Hart vs Tony Rock and Kevin
Hart genius that he is just waited and
kept sitting on the fact that
Tony Rock is Chris Rock's brother.
Every time Tony would
throw something good at,
um,
you know,
you're only famous
because of this and that,
whatever.
And like,
and Kevin just kept waiting
so that by the time,
10 jokes in when he said,
you're just a bung gas brother,
you know what I mean?
Or whatever the place just,
it was over because he
waited so long for it.
Everybody thought it was going to be each
one and he'd get them on another one.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Those rows battles can be brutal,
man.
Yeah.
Jen Murphy and her ex boyfriend.
Oh,
that was great.
Oh good Lord.
She eviscerated that poor character.
Yeah,
it was fun.
Those,
those a roast battles are fun because
you know one of the things about it is
that it's like a writer's show.
It's like it's a joke writing affair.
That's what it's all about.
So I'll just about writing
jokes clowning each other.
I love that he makes them hug
it out at the end of it too.
Yeah.
Every,
everyone ends in a hug.
There was one time it didn't and then
into [inaudible] the person who won didn't
want to hug the other person,
but the whole room turns on you quick.
Even though he had just won,
he didn't want a hug,
so he goes,
man,
fuck this.
And started walking in.
The whole crowd went from
clapping too with the guy.
Like he lost respect immediately and had
to really like the rest of the night he
was working on fixing his
reputation with everyone.
Why they clean it up quick
by not respecting the role,
the house,
the role,
ghetto fast ferry space.
That's a shirt.
That's a white guy.
We don't know for sure.
That should be a band.
Very good.
Oh,
fast.
Sounds like a good band.
Name.
One of the very ghetto fast concert.
Very ghetto.
Fast as in town.
Dude.
I hear they're on some new math.
Vgf Baby.
I could start a band right now.
Let's do it.
Four of us.
Very ghetto.
Fast.
Yeah.
We can't say what the CIC
sang UNL dance right quick.
Come on,
y'all just shake beads in her hair.
Vgf back again.
Did you ever go to the comedy festivals?
Have you ever been to Montreal
or any of those festivals?
I've never been there.
Montreal.
I have done a couple
like one night things.
I was with you.
Toronto,
Toronto just for laughs one nighter and
I did one with Jeff Ross and Chicago,
um,
a couple of years ago
and yeah,
no,
I done the Travers city comedy festival,
which was awesome.
Great Festival.
Jeff Garlin and Michael Moore,
the filmmaker,
a run a comedy festival
each year in traverse city,
which is like Trevor City.
It's like northern Michigan.
It's like the cherry capital.
It's,
Oh shit.
Unbelievable.
It's a winter fest basically,
and they shut down this
whole strip of this amazing,
like it looks like,
like wonder some winter wonderland city
and they have Ferris wheels and all this
big sledding hills and
all this winter stuff.
Everybody dresses all warm
and I've never heard of this.
It's awesome.
That's incredible.
That's awesome.
And they do this every year in the winter.
But what time in the winter?
Uh,
I'm not sure.
Who would you do it with?
I did it with,
uh,
Kirk Fox matted girth.
Stephanie,
some Bari Garland.
Sinbad,
Dave Foley.
Yeah.
How was day four was doing?
Stand up.
How is it?
Well,
I did an improvised show with him where?
Wait,
what was the thing?
Oh yeah,
it was the setlist show where you don't,
you don't know what you're going to
do until you look or look behind you.
And this was in a theater,
right?
And a word pops up and you have to
pretend like you have a bit about that.
You just roll with it.
He ended up taking his pants down.
It was epic theater exploded
because they're not,
you want to talk about going on the
road and you know what you can do and
pushing the lines.
Well,
they were really weren't expecting
that in good old winter land.
Come on,
let me make you Cherry Pie.
Welcome to Travers city.
Like that's that Seti.
Dave Foley just goes,
what?
Powell and I remember we were downstairs,
the green rooms in a basement.
You just heard this roar and there was
a TV but it was muted and we're all
sitting in the green room and
you hear this bra and we're like,
what the hell?
And you look and Dave Foley's pants where?
At his ankles on this
TV in the green room.
And we're just like,
Holy Shit.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Fully is a killer joke writer man.
Oh yeah,
he,
I was crushed.
I was really happy when he decided to
do some stand up because it was one of
those things.
It's the same kind of a thing
where even though he's a,
an established actor and a established
hilarious guy from kids in the hall,
there's still,
he couldn't always get work.
You know,
he's having a hard time
getting gigs and you,
you know,
you have to get picked to do gigs.
It's just the way it is.
You get cast,
you know,
or you do your own thing.
You create your own thing or you get cast
and then the ultimate create your own
thing.
You stand up.
So he just started doing stand up,
you know,
I just want to see it.
I haven't seen a standup.
I would imagine it'd be very funny.
Yeah.
He's just such a smart dude.
He's one of the smartest people I know.
He's such a fascinating character.
Or would amaze me.
What really ended up stealing
that festival for me was,
you know,
Sinbad did a show and I
was thinking of myself,
I,
you know what?
I'm going to go do this other show I'm
going to through right after this spot.
I'm gonna go do this because
it's at the festivals.
There's always multiple
spots you could do.
But I had a chance to sit in the back of
the theater and watch Sinbad for a few
minutes and I was amazed.
Everything that I heard about
him went out the window.
When I saw Sinbad live,
I was honestly shocked
at what he was doing.
I was shocked because I was for sure
thinking I was going to watch every single
thing that I've been told
about him is that he's a hack.
He's this,
he's that Bobby by sucks,
he's washed up and next thing you know
I'm sitting in the back of this theater,
just slow clapping like that.
I swear.
Premises delivery,
like what was so special about it?
He would go in and out of stuff.
He was just crush,
crush and then he would go,
what's next?
And he would just wait for somebody in
the crowd to say anything and he would
literally,
basically he was thunder plussing it.
He was staying stand
up on the spotting it,
but he has 35 years of bank and confidence
and energy and I don't think he's
always been that way.
Like I remember how goofy is specials
looked when I was kid when I was a kid.
I don't really remember anything that he
talked about really is and that's all I
can remember.
Go Ham,
I go,
hey,
I'm a go.
But he was on fire man.
Not the type of stuff that
I was expecting at all.
Like what kind of premises do we use?
Surprise by luck.
His points or really?
Yeah.
When,
how long ago was this?
This was a about a year ago.
You don't hear about
them that much anymore?
That's where we had him on
killed Tony a couple months ago.
Him and Jeff Garlin on the same episode
and that was a blast and we got to see
some of it there too.
He's great at riffing then.
No Shit.
Just super nice.
She tried to say you're in black guys.
Just Sinbad,
32 dark posts.
Only his pants though.
Those hammer pants.
If you could bring those back,
there'll be a strong move cause someone
has to be the first person to slap those
pants on in the first place.
We're wearing them and
silver lake MC hammer pants,
ironically,
and they are garland and Sinbad.
Samsung Hammer.
I did send that.
I've never met the gentleman.
He was really,
really nice.
You'd be really surprised.
I bet he's a nice guy.
Is Never,
never heard a bad thing about him.
Never heard he's a duck.
This episode with Garland and Sinbad,
I think it's like 35 and 32 years or
something crazy that they've both been
doing.
Standups are the comedians.
I think there was one or two that
had their first time ever on stage.
We're getting immediate feedback from
over 60 years of comedy experience.
70 if you throw in me and Brian,
but that's crazy.
Yeah,
towels.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's another funny thing
that I'll tell you the only,
the only thing on his rider,
I swear to God,
I got to the,
I got the,
in the green room,
there's a little cabinet things sitting
there and it just had 10 hand towels on
it.
And there was a note that said for
Sinbad and the assistant that brought me
down,
I go,
what's that?
And she goes,
that's the only thing on his
rider 10 clean hand towels.
So hilarious.
Black dudes love towels.
It's true of to pat the forehead down.
You know,
Bill Byrd did that and his latest special
I was gonna I was gonna call him up
and ask him it.
He
had his forehead down with a towel yet
sitting there and the other thing was
kind of,
he had a glass of water.
It was just a glass,
not a bottle of water with
a cap and actual class.
Like he's,
he's so old school.
He had a glass of water on stage.
Like you could totally
see him doing that too.
Yeah,
it probably was tap water,
Eh,
I'll just take it out of the phone.
These guys now everybody's
got a bottle of water.
Have fucking bottled water.
I think there's this,
I think it's a fucking scam.
That's what I think.
I think they just take that shit out
and they s they sell it to you and they
look at you like you're a fucking
idiot when you pay for it.
Every time with the cap,
what I'm doing,
what am I,
why?
Why am I putting in time on this job?
He's got one of those voices,
man.
You know,
he's a guy that has also
benefited tremendously from
podcasts because he goes on
these rifts every week.
He does his podcast completely by himself,
which I've done before,
which is fucking hard,
man.
It's really hard.
It's hard not to a slide
into a being boring,
you know?
Right.
The monotonous,
it's hard to be entertaining,
but he's,
he's fucking entertaining doing it.
And there's something to be
said for not having video too.
There's something to be said for video,
but there's also something
to be said for just audio.
Just audio is a type of entertainment,
like,
like putting it down on youtube,
putting a podcast on
Vimeo and all that stuff.
It's all great.
Nothing,
nothing bad about it.
But occasionally I just like listening
to shit and burst podcasts the best for
that because it's just him.
You could tell it's just him with a
couple pieces of paper at his desk and he
just ran.
You know,
it's interesting listening to kill Tony
versus watching killed Tony because I
usually always watch it,
but lately I've been listening to it and
you don't judge who's on stage as much
when you,
you're just listening
to this open miker talk.
Sometimes it's actually way better
to listen to the audio because you're
actually hearing what he's trying to say
like almost as a character instead of
seeing the video part.
It's,
it's neat how some podcasts changed.
Well even comedy,
I think comedy,
I love watching it but I also love just
lying back like with some headsets on
closing my eyes,
listening to a set.
I like doing that too.
You know,
I like,
you know,
like when I was a kid we
used to listen to albums.
Like that was a big thing.
Like comedy albums,
like Cheech and Chong and you know,
listen to old bill Cosby albums and
when we would sit and listen to them,
I would just be like,
you'd just be sitting around
listening to the words,
just looking off in the room you were in,
you know,
you,
it's,
there's something about that,
the allowing your mind to like go on a
little dance and not getting any visual
stimuli.
You're just sort of it and putting
it all together in your mind.
Some about that.
That's really fucking cool.
It's,
it's not,
I w I would definitely like if someone
had to choose between never seeing people
again or always seeing people again,
I would always go with
always seeing people again.
But there's something cool
about just comedy cds.
Yeah.
It's Kinda like when you read a
book and you're,
and you're thinking about
something else and you're like,
oh I have to go back to the beginning
when you watch video and audio cause
you're focusing,
I'm like,
oh that guy's hair's weird.
Or Why is he wearing that?
Instead of like you listen to the judge,
she like,
oh,
he's actually funny.
If I was just listening and not looking
at his outfit and how weird he is,
whatever,
whatever it is.
But then there's people that you know
like Joey will you want to see him?
Exactly.
When do you think you to say?
Yeah,
I just want to say I think it's kind
of cool for us because I mean sometimes
people don't know what we look like.
They're just like,
oh,
you're pretty.
And they like,
Tony should have your own show.
I'm a producer.
Producer,
Huh?
Yeah.
Do you guys get Weirdos fall
on you because of the show?
Oh,
oh my God.
The weirdest people.
I someone made a sub reddit.
Brian sent it to me.
Sub reddit just for me,
except they,
he took,
I mean,
it's like flattering.
It's slash creepy mean and they took
my Instagram pictures and it's like a
whole,
just like just my pictures
and just like one word,
titles like sunbathing or legs,
like whatever it,
my picture is,
they're just,
it's the description
of categorize them all.
Oh yeah.
Oof.
It's very creepy.
How many dudes do you think if you
had it like a round about number of,
of spanked it to pictures
while these two in this room?
I mean,
Tony's done it together.
I'm looking at the phone.
Me and Tony,
you're lucky.
Strong.
That whole sentence together.
That's it.
That's the nickname he has for me.
Tony.
Tony's do that all the time.
That's probably who made
the subreddit by the way.
Oh God.
He definitely spanked it to my,
uh,
both of our picture is how
long do you girls think
you'll keep doing this and do you think,
do you like,
do you have a plan?
Do you,
do,
do you have like a,
like a transition to becoming
a professional standup plan?
I said what you guys would love to do.
You want to do your own podcast?
Um,
yeah,
I've thought about doing
my own podcast for sure.
We've talked about it.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
I think that the benefit of killed Tony,
there's still so much benefit for
us because there's so much that we,
I feel like I've learned in
like a small amount of time.
Just from being like holding yourself to
a standard of writing in this stuff all
the time and meeting people and getting
feedback from people who've been doing
it longer.
That's,
you can't ask for that.
You can't find that.
Right.
It's true.
And you guys ever have a material cross?
What are each other's?
Yeah,
like current event type shit.
Oh you're writing a new minute every week.
Her and I are totally different.
Yeah.
Completely different.
The comedians like,
yeah,
two completely different styles,
different voices.
Kevin talks a little bit more about
topical stuff and her family and Sarah
organically
just ends up talking about like the
most random small thing you can imagine.
You know how like there's
like some subjects when you
go to an open mic night or
any sort of a show where guys
are working on new material.
Like,
um,
remember that one Brian,
when the Chinese uh,
pilot crashed into the American pilot
and his name was one way and that became
like the most ridiculously overused
joke in the history of comedy.
Like everybody had a joke about this guy
named Wong way who's a Chinese fighter
pilot.
Everyone has a Tinder joke.
Everyone has a cosmic joke.
Right?
Yeah.
Cosby's another perfect example.
Like if you go on an
open Mike night today,
most likely five or six people before
you have already told Cosby jokes.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well like it's kind of
like you said earlier.
Um,
I feel like I only,
I,
there's things that people talk about
all the time and I know it's going to be
what everyone's saying at an open mic.
But if I feel like I have a better joke
about it than everybody else and I'll
absolutely do it,
I don't care if everyone else talking
about it because if it's better than
everyone else's,
it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Good for you.
You don't have to,
just because the subjects are have been,
you can,
especially if you're
just working on jokes,
which is essentially what you're doing.
You're doing sets of new shit every week.
You're,
you're like in a constant
state of working on jokes.
Yeah.
Right.
Like we've never had
close to the same topic.
No,
not at all.
Yeah.
Sarah pick something and
then she focuses on it.
Yeah.
Josh me like gum,
Minty Gum,
dust pans pyramid.
Vasco seashells.
Mayonnaise.
Yeah.
Just want to put the crackers.
Yes.
Break it down.
Yeah.
Crack.
That's how she's a third slot.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Easter baskets.
Let's talk about them and I hate him.
Do you think it's tougher
to be a check and do standup comedy?
Ooh,
I like this question.
I think it's,
I think there's two different advantages.
Like think that,
um,
sometimes it's like,
oh,
they only get this stuff because
they're girls or you know,
like,
you know,
they,
they flirt their way to stage time or
whatever and then at the same time they're
like,
not that many girls.
I mean,
Sarah and I started killed
Tony because it was,
you said it was all guy comedians in the
beginning and then we became to regular
girls at the end of it.
And it's just,
there's not that much
competition right now.
Especially right now.
I feel like there's not a
lot of girls in New York.
I know there's a lot more girls,
but I think that it gives
us an advantage and like,
I think that if you're funny,
you're funny.
If you work hard,
you work hard.
Yeah.
Those are two definite truth.
If you're funny,
you're funny.
If you work hard,
you work hard,
that's for sure.
But I think that what I've
always thought was that,
uh,
we're lucky as men that we could get
away with a lot more subject matter.
Like a man can talk about
politics and critique like,
like what's going on in the world.
But I think if women start doing that,
like men,
unless they're like really established,
I get,
unless you're like someone that
you come to see you do that,
like maybe Janine Garafalo or someone
that you go to expect that if an unknown
Gow is on stage and she starts
criticizing the current administration,
like who's this fucking know it all bitch,
you know?
Right,
right.
And then like guys,
a lot of guys do not like hearing women
like in position of speaking if they
have differing opinions.
You know,
like during like there's a lot of people,
especially men,
they're in this constant state of like
a conflict and competition at work.
They're constantly at work,
you know,
battling back and forth with their boss,
dealing with the clients
and this and that,
and they're in this constant state.
Then they go to a comedy club and some
chick has onstage and she's talking about
the depth,
the difference between the Republicans,
Democrats,
you don't know shit about real public.
Let me guess.
You fucking lived hard,
you know what I mean?
Like they're in this constant
state and a woman going on stage.
I think it's a,
it's an extra little hill to climb and
then sex is also what I would think is an
extra little hill to climb because it
dude can talk about just and all over the
place or you know,
you can talk about basically anything,
right?
But a girl talking about sex,
it gets really tricky.
Like girls a clam up,
they'll,
they'll think you're a whore.
You know,
guys,
you know,
don't know when you know
they should laugh or what,
what's acceptable at a chicken.
Get Away with talking about.
Yeah,
I had a lot of trouble with that when I
first started because everyone tells you
to talk about your life and I'm 24,
like I'm having sex and like doing this,
you know,
I'm like,
that's my life right now.
And people are like,
Oh,
don't talk about having
sex because that's hacky.
That's what all girls talk about.
And it's like,
that's cause we're having sex.
You know,
like you're talking about
things you're doing.
Um,
I just say whatever I want.
That's good.
Yeah.
I don't care.
I don't really care.
I just,
my goal is just like,
I feel like as long as
I come out of it funny,
if you come out,
if you come out of your
set and it was a funny set,
no one's going to be mad at you.
So if he was funny,
they can't be like,
oh,
stupid funny girl.
I mean they can,
but then,
and it's obviously,
it's obvious if you see like Whitney
Cummings or Chelsea handler or you know,
even Joan Rivers,
like you could talk about whatever
the fuck you want to talk about.
You know,
I just,
I've always felt like as a woman,
like it's probably like there's
an extra little hump to crop.
Oh,
they're definitely
feel like ladies are definitely adi ladies
in the audience are tougher on women
than they are on guys for sure.
Because almost all you can adjust,
almost see it on their faces.
That's another funny
thing about kill Tony,
is we have that perspective where you're
sitting at a table facing the audience
and you get to see what they're
looking at for a change.
Like instead of just when you're on stage,
that camera one perspective,
you see the looks on their faces sometimes
when this type of person's honor,
that type of persons on and women,
it seems like all of them were like,
well,
I know I have to be better than her,
so let's see what she can do.
And then you watch them get beat
out of them after a few seconds.
You know?
It's like,
ah,
okay.
I get it.
She's a pro and I don't,
and I judged too quick.
I think there's some women that
just are fans of other women.
Totally.
There's some that you love them.
I love women.
Oh,
okay.
Are you met?
You love the women that don't love women?
You know,
like there's some women that
only have like male friends.
They don't have any women friends.
Those are the crazy ones.
Are they as crazy as that
dude's only have girlfriends?
You know,
my,
my wife had this friend who had a guy
friend for like the longest time and I was
like,
that dude is gay.
And they're like,
no,
no.
He's got a kid.
That dude,
he's gay.
No,
he's got a kid.
he's a father.
That dude is gay.
It turns out in his
forties that dude is gay.
He's like,
fucking,
I can't carry this anymore.
And I was like,
I told Joe,
Joe,
did he start talking gay media?
It wasn't,
you know what it was,
man,
it was,
there was like,
he was like way too into
talking about like girl stuff.
Like he was way too into talking about
like shopping and gossip and I was
listening to him talk.
I was like,
what is going on here?
What is this like?
There was this extreme lack of,
of uh,
I mean it wasn't,
it was more like he was like all male
woman than it was that he was homosexual
because I never felt like
he was hitting on me.
He's a power bottom.
Maybe it's a problem to
bottom that fuck it back.
But I'm not saying you never showed
any like sexual attraction to men.
He just showed such feminine
behavior patterns that I was like,
this is wrong,
this is incorrect here.
Like what's going on?
What's she playing?
They soon split up.
What's up?
Then
the whole thing was a disaster.
But it's just,
it's uh,
it's,
it's fascinating to see someone like that.
It's like battling it,
fighting it off.
The poor bastard just gave in and it's 40.
It's just
nice.
Not like a 20 year old boyfriend bowing
out of the closet and into the funnier
he's flaming get it.
Yeah.
I was hanging out with mostly women,
but I think it's mostly due to my,
like growing up with my
mom and my sister though.
But you know,
a lot of dudes are friends with.
Yeah.
But,
but in general,
I like in high school
only had girlfriends,
never know guy friends.
And then,
uh,
in,
in real life,
you know,
like most of the time I'm
usually hanging out with girls.
I'm not calling up guys going,
hey,
let's go to a bar and get some drinks.
I'm calling up a girl and going,
hey,
let's go to a bar and get some drinks.
I'm never calling guys,
you know,
except for like,
I'm not like,
when was the last time I called him of
you guys going to come in here sweating?
I can't handle it
like TMZ and I live in
a pink house and Shit.
Hey,
you put that in there.
I saw you slip that in there.
The fuck dude,
the cars.
Have you guys talked at all about all
this racial shit that's going on in the
Ferguson riots and talking
about any of that on stage?
So deep.
Have you seen that new Ferguson video?
Supposedly,
but it's,
they don't,
they can't verify if it's real or not.
What are you talking about?
It's a,
the guy that got shot,
uh,
him like mugging an old man.
I solid.
It's bullshit.
Is it bullshit?
God?
Cause I Snopes says an unknown.
If it's what makes you
think it's bullshit?
Because it doesn't even
look like the same guy.
Oh,
it's just like people,
people still think all black guys look
the same and it just blatantly show.
It's like,
what the fuck are you saying?
Whoa.
That's what that's saying.
That they don't,
I think
they look a lot alike.
Some of,
Whoa,
some of those.
Some of them,
yes.
Okay.
White people just look very different.
All white people are all like
different facial features.
Rude as fuck.
No,
that's not rude.
Why?
People are so,
they all look the same.
I get them confused all the time.
Yeah.
And why people are so different.
Asians look the same.
Puerto Rican women a lot of times with
the same whoa will never work in this
town again.
Wow.
How dare you.
Not Racist at all.
I'm just saying like I feel
like smell the same way.
I'm just saying like white people
are the only ones that look really,
really different all the time.
You don't agree with that?
No.
Oh,
maybe I haven't seen enough people.
You're only 24 kid when you accumulate
a database like we have and you want to
see black people with
the lights off anyways.
Anyways,
I don't think it's him in the video.
And I think people are
just looking for stuff in,
regardless if he wasn't
mugging an old man,
the video starts in the middle of a fight.
So you don't know what happens,
right?
So people are just like,
oh,
he's just beating up this old dude.
And it doesn't matter.
It doesn't mean you can kill someone
on a sidewalk for selling cigarettes no
matter what they used to do.
You know what I'm most
fascinated by with this?
Not even just that it's a,
it seems like weird still stuck
when it comes to race relations.
Like we're still stuck in
this US versus them mentality.
That just hasn't gone away that
that shocks me.
But what really shocks me is that they
just pick this one event and this one
event all of a sudden caught fire and
became giant because there's so many of
them.
If you look at the numbers of people,
like there's a,
there's a website that tracks the numbers
of people killed by cops every year.
And uh,
like I think it's called cop killer.
Dot.
Something or another.
Somebody tweeted to me
today and I was like,
what?
And you,
you look at it like there's like the fact
that one just caught on and took off.
It's weird.
Yeah.
But that happens.
It happens.
Like one thing like makes its way to the
forefront and then the public grabs a
hold of it and then next thing you know
they're out in the street and then for
it to happen.
And then right after that
Eric Gardner case happened.
Like,
Whoa,
it's just like out of control.
You know,
it's a tsunami.
Did you see the hashtags
after that whole thing happened?
The climbing wall,
white and living while Black Hashtags,
they're insane.
It's a bunch of white people hashtagging
crying while white and admitting to
crimes they've done that.
The police,
like I got pulled over drunk with a gun
in my car and the police gave me a ride
home.
And it's like all these
things that they're admitting
and then the living wall,
black ones were all
black people were like,
I went into a store and got questioned.
Right.
And it was like just
the difference between,
it was pretty interesting.
I've definitely seen a lot
of those living wall black,
you know,
look,
I could see a lot of
different sides to this.
The bottom line of all of it is we have
to at a certain point in time realize he
can't just keep like letting these poor
people in these shit neighborhoods keep
growing up in these neighborhoods
and not try to help out.
Right.
And I try to fix that spot.
There's those spots that we have
in our country that are like really
impoverished.
Those are critical like errors in our
system and we're just sort of like letting
them percolate.
Yep.
Less jail is more education I think.
Fuckable it's also like you could create
a bunch of Nice people instead of like
having people grow up,
disenfranchise and fucked up.
You'd have people grow up
to contribute to society,
but everyone's got this me or
US versus them or you know,
all for one and you know,
like,
we don't have this,
this idea of treating
the human race was like,
like a cola.
If we treat treated,
the human race is like an organism,
like one collective Oregon,
a team,
you would say,
okay,
well we've got an issue here.
Let's just clean up this issue and
figure out a way to manage everything
together.
Treat it as like one super organism.
That's our country.
One job.
Instead of thinking of it as just a bunch
of people living together on a patch
of dirt,
let's think of the human beings.
It's like,
look,
we can't separate from each other
unless you're a Weirdo hermit type dude.
This wants to live in the woods.
Everybody's around everybody.
We're all,
we all feed off of each other.
We interact with each other.
We exchange goods,
we exchange services.
I mean we need each other.
We're a part of a team,
whether we like it or not,
human beings,
everybody we were around
is a part of our community.
So I think some one,
one of these presidents somewhere along
the line is going to have to figure out
a way to,
to say that in a way on television
where people listening go,
oh yeah.
So instead of saying,
well,
these welfare moms try to give
all these fucking welfare model,
you know,
every baby they have,
they get another check.
Like,
okay,
yeah,
it,
that's not,
this is the least of our worries.
Yeah.
The big worry is this,
more or less people are growing up in
this crime ridden neighborhoods and then
they're just growing up and becoming
adults and then they go out into the world
and like,
you're dealing with a
bunch of human problems.
Yeah.
The worst is really the prison system.
Fuck.
Yeah.
It is.
It's the worst of the worst of the worst
of our problems because I bet I've been
working on something recently that
us to do with presence and uh,
and uh,
so I found out about how the rest of the
world does it and how they completely
can rehabilitate people and
get them back in society.
And it's totally the
opposite here where the,
you basically create a worse criminal
by sending them to prison and then you
send back out again and they
have no idea what to do.
Not only that,
they make money off putting him in prison,
which is the most insane thing ever.
This is a,
a large number of private
prisons in this country.
And they lobby to make sure that laws are
in place that allow them to keep their
prisons full.
Yeah.
And they make all that money that they
get from the government and they'll give
the,
the prisoner,
like at the tent city in Arizona,
they eat like 60 cents.
I think their meals are 40 cents per day
is what they're feeding the prisoner.
And they brag about feeding the dogs
more valuable food during the day.
Like the dog seat,
like 70 cents worth of food per day.
Yeah.
And they make them wear pink.
Yeah,
that's so,
and then they dump them out on the streets
when they're done with their sentence
and they don't have a job,
but they don't have good health.
And then they go and rob
a store again and again.
It could happen to anybody,
you know?
I mean,
we're going to be in Phoenix.
What?
Tomorrow?
Tomorrow and something could happen.
You know they see Ari and his weird nose.
Do you think they might
think he's a terrorist?
Maybe?
No.
Sure.
If we're all together,
I think we'll,
we'll,
we'll tell them.
Luckily,
luckily our,
he wears pink underwear anyway,
so we'll just Google his name and show
that he's a hilarious standup comedian.
Look,
sir,
this is a clip from his upcoming comedy
central special called paid regular?
Yes.
They're also Aaron,
his other one.
Bearen his other one now.
What was his last one?
Ari's last special.
Passive aggressive.
Yeah.
The cost somewhere in that one too.
Oh yeah.
Civic Hall across a revenge
of the Holocaust was a CD.
Did he did these three things out?
Let's got revenge of the Holocaust.
Passive aggressive and then
this new one paid regular.
Amazing.
When are you going to release something,
Tony?
Hinchcliffe.
I know you're chomping at the bit.
You hear me talk about Ra and I see
a little fucking juices get flying.
Wait.
You get excited and tense.
That's what gives you these panic attacks.
So we give you,
it gives you weird ear pains.
Ah,
I'm going deaf.
No,
you're just freaking the fuck out.
Wait,
we're
waiting for somebody
to offer me something.
Okay.
Here's the next question.
When are you gonna quit the cancer sticks?
When,
uh,
when I,
when somebody offers
me to shoot a special,
that's what you're going to quit?
Yeah.
And then you'd be like,
I can't quit now to fuck me up.
I need him.
I need him to calm me down
while I'm getting ready.
As soon as the specials over.
And then after the specialist over,
you're like,
I gotta write new material.
I can't be thinking about anything
other than writing new material.
Once I have a new hour,
then I'm gonna quit the cigarettes.
Yeah.
And then I'm going to get my own TV show
and I can't quit smoking then cause I
want to smoke on the TV show.
Bring it back like Carson,
why don't you try cigars?
Cigars.
You don't inhale.
They're supposed to be
better for your health.
That's how we'll Phil
Hartman quit smoking.
You could be just like Phil,
it's true and I would do that,
but everybody complains about everything.
You know the smell and
then this and and that.
Everybody's going to
complain no matter what.
That's your look.
That's your sugar.
Shut up.
I'm trying to form a fucking image here.
That's your look dude.
Cigars,
Fedora,
cigar.
Hey guys,
let me fucking talk.
Cowboy.
No,
no,
no.
For Dora,
Bro,
maybe.
Maybe a cowboy hat.
Okay.
Listen.
Vast cowboy hat.
Cigar.
No,
no cowboy hats.
I'm going to work.
I kiss him,
but you look just like
woody from toy story.
If he wears a cowboy hat,
here's,
here's the deal.
Three piece suit Mohawk.
Okay.
Three piece suit with a fucking solid
Mohawk smoking a cigar on stage.
What happened to all gold?
See gold tie the mastermind.
I could see you with a scarf.
If you wear a scarf,
you're either gay or a cowboy.
You have two options,
right?
Yeah.
Tony,
you look a lot like,
yeah,
you can't be like a straight guy out
for a night on the town with a fucking
Bandana around your neck.
Well,
what kind of a guy wears
a Bandana around his neck?
Tony in this cartoon,
the guy who wants you to choke
them unconscious and fuck him.
Well the guy wants you to squeeze that
thing until he blacks out and give them a
good fucking,
there's no other reason for a man unless
he's worried about dirt getting into
his neck,
you know?
That's why I better get an
audition for woody if that happens.
Do you think there'll be a live action
toy story and maybe why would they do
that?
There'll be so dumb.
The kids would be like,
why are we seeing real people?
Where the fuck is woody
playing with other adults?
Toy Box.
You'd perfect.
Weird.
Yeah.
You'd be perfect for the twilight
zone version when woody comes to life.
Yes.
Yeah.
Like the parents don't see it,
but the kid does and you're giving the
kid really fucked up advice and you're
woody.
Yeah.
And the parents come in and all of a
sudden you're back to being like a wooden
doll again.
Mommy,
my doll was just smoking a cigarette.
Dude,
I watched,
I binge watched a few of those recently.
Those old school twilight
zone episodes the best.
It was so amazing.
You know,
one of the cool things about it is they
had so many different subjects to choose
from and they had to do it with a,
like a relatively small budget.
I didn't have much in terms
of like special effects.
I'll give you,
go back and look at like some
of the old special effects.
They were unbelievably laughable.
Yeah.
I just watched toilet isn't
this morning before I really,
which episode was it?
Uh,
the one beauty is only skin deep,
great episode where the
girls wants to fix our face.
They don't show it the whole time.
They don't show the doctors' faces either.
And at the end she's like
beautiful and everyone's hideous.
Oh Wow.
And they're like,
we're going to send you
off with people like you.
And at the end,
it's just like,
she just wanted to be like them.
Oh my God.
Oh,
spoiler alert.
It doesn't matter if they're so awesome.
When the guy was cleaning
on the airplane wing.
Yes.
That one was William Shatner.
Cause I'm mad at the wake of this plane.
Amazing.
And the fucking outfit,
the thing hat on was so bad,
so bad.
He was a furry,
it was essentially like a fairy,
like one of those people that goes to
those conventions dresses up like a
mascot.
Yeah.
That's what it looked like.
And he slipped,
pretended to be like
this like Gremlin John,
like pig Chewbacca picture with
John Lithgow was the remake of it.
Yeah.
In the
movie.
Which is really good too.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Their premise is we're so genius.
There was so many good ones.
My favorite one was to serve man.
Did you ever see that one?
Oh it's the best.
These aliens came down and they,
they brought with them this book and um,
they were going to take people back
to their planet and people like it all
signed up to go to their planet.
And the,
the idea of the book was they're
going to teach people about all their
technology and how to,
you know,
how to space travel and all that shit.
So they get these people on the ship
and as they're hurting them on the ship,
they're all like much bigger than regular
people as they're hurting them on the
ship.
The Guy Yells at,
or it's a guy or a girl yells out,
it's a cookbook to serve man.
Like,
you know,
like they thought that the title to
serve man was giving man all these
instructions and they deciphered all the
different shit and they realize they're
going to eat all these
people and so taken off.
They take off of these
people in this space share,
but they're going to eat him.
Wow.
It's great.
And it's so Cokie looking
like everything is hokey.
This space guys are hooky.
Look into space.
Ship is hokey looking.
Hitchcock holds up to fuck.
Yag does amazing.
Well that's when we were talking about,
um,
like gene wilder and
Richard Pryor movies like I,
I almost don't want to watch
them to see if they hold up.
But Richard Pryor stand up,
totally holds up.
Totally holds up an undisputed,
undisputed like number one of all time.
Well I think that he was
like the most influential,
right?
He was like the most powerful,
he's like changed what comedy is too.
A lot of people like his honesty,
like when he was on fire and Shit,
you know,
it changed what comedy is to people.
Yeah.
I just like when you were talking about
sitting in the back of the room and
watching people laugh,
that was like the moment that I ever
realized how crazy standup comedy was.
My parents took me to see
live in the sunset strip.
I was in the audience.
I was like,
you know,
little kid 13 or something and all these
people were like falling down laughing
in the crowd.
And I remember thinking,
I've never seen this before.
I give us a bit,
I've been a lot of comedy movies.
I've never seen anybody fallen down.
And this guy's just talking.
I was like,
I was thinking like,
this is the funniest thing
I probably have ever seen.
And he's just talking
crazy.
He's the one.
Yeah.
And that was at the store
in the fucking main room.
That's theirs to something
weird about that.
Like when you're standing
on that stage in that,
in that room and you realize,
Whoa,
this is where Richard Pryor film
live on the sunset strip mother.
So cool.
Yeah.
Do you guys uh,
get that like weird charge at a
working at the store because of that?
Because of the history behind it all.
Totally cool.
How you're,
how you perceive it.
Like if reception of the store just
changes like the money that you hang out
there,
the more that you're immersed in it.
The last weird today is,
and then you bring your normal
friends and they're like,
what the hell?
Yeah.
You bring non comedians the store and
they're like,
what is this?
How is this?
Okay.
Why are these people,
how often do you come here again,
this is your home.
What the hell?
Well for Ari,
it really was.
His home are used to walk there.
He lived right up the street.
He lived right next to pink dot.
So he would just walk to his fucking
apartment and walked down the store every
day and he was there every day.
That dude lived in that place.
I remember when I first
started hanging out there,
someone in the green room called
it the island of misfit toys.
I was like,
that's perfect.
Exactly what it is.
Yeah.
I think that was Mitsis term.
I'm pretty sure.
I think it was right.
What do you write in their felony?
Got an idea.
Got something crazy
little comedy on the mind.
No,
something funny happened
last night though.
I uh,
I was driving home from the,
I are driving to the comedy store from
the Ice House and there was an amber
alert on a,
on the radio and the guy
had a nicer car than mine.
The abductor,
and I'm like,
this guy needs to get his
fucking life together.
2014 Mercedes Benz I'm supposed
to be on the lookout for.
Really?
Yeah.
Well yeah,
but it must be really hard to make it
in life when you're like a serial killer
or like a child molester or
something along those lines,
like struggling with that.
And being super successful.
Yeah.
That's kind of crazy.
That's what I'm thinking.
This guy lives the kind of life where
he wanted to be seen in a 2014 Mercedes
Benz and now he's the only guy with a
2014 Mercedes Benz who wants nobody to see
it.
Maybe he only likes kids with tastes.
It's like some American
psycho stuff right there.
Yeah,
right.
Well wasn't that the case with the,
there was a guy that was on that show,
seventh heaven.
It turned out he was molesting
girls like young girls like that.
I mean obviously that guy get a Mercedes.
Right?
I mean it's,
sometimes people do get super
wealthy while being sex criminals.
Yeah.
Such a crush on him.
When I was younger did June,
he could've gotten it for probably
the dad from seventh heaven.
How old?
How old do you think you would have to
be before you would give it up to him?
Oh my God.
When I was watching [inaudible] was
watching it when I was like 12 or 13 four
and if you had met him at that time,
wouldn't have fucked him cause I
wasn't like a whore 14 year old.
Right.
But would would,
do you think that you would have been
like interested in hanging around with
them?
I was obsessed with them.
I was like so good dad from seventh.
I was obsessed with him.
I kind of liked him too on the show.
Seventh Heaven.
Yeah.
So you guys were children.
You guys were fans of seven.
I used to watch it in like fifth grade.
I've seen every episode
and I watched him again.
I'm not going to lie like four months ago.
Whoa,
whoa.
That's how I learn what huffing
was because one of them,
so was how you were saying
that's when you know you uh,
you fucking have fucked up beyond
fucked up when they were arresting you,
you got paint all over your face.
Paint on his face.
No huffing.
No.
Oh yeah.
That shit's,
people just get caught huffing.
If you've seen those photos of dudes,
there's this one dude just
looks method out of his mind,
like silver paint all over his nose and
his lips and his mouth and you're like,
oh my God,
dude,
welcome to this is,
this is the bottom.
Just hit the bottom.
It doesn't go anywhere from here,
but up.
That's some of the best
episodes of cops too,
when they always catch
the guys with the silver,
but it's something about,
I wasn't doing nothing.
Officer don't shows that
appeals to like younger people.
That would look a little
bit more innocent,
right?
Yeah.
Now I watch it.
I'm like,
Whoa,
that was a mister rack.
Like I thought I was learning so much.
I'm like,
I'm in the world and learning
about huffing and ready.
It's great.
Let's go.
That's how I learned a lot of stuff.
Dump show.
That's one of the things
you don't like as an adult.
You don't always piece it together
like this show is awesome.
If you're 12 you know?
Yeah,
it's stupid as fuck when you're 15
but when you're 12 it's awesome.
When you 30,
you can't watch that,
but when you're 12,
it gets you just,
it hits a certain tone inside of you.
It's like the costumes in the
twilight zone and you're like,
how did I think this was scary?
But that was a long time ago,
you know?
Wow.
This seventh Heaven Guy,
like that show was all
about like a preacher,
right
in his family.
He's the preacher.
He was a preacher in the show.
Yeah.
Maybe he was just doing
research for his role.
I just found a great video of this
paint huffer and series of his,
uh,
over 14 years of his,
his mugshots.
Oh,
good Lord.
And it's a,
it starts off 14 years.
Guy Roast battle does look
like someone pretty crazy.
2009,
whoa.
Later in 2009,
he didn't look so good.
Oh my [inaudible] in the Ronald McDonald.
Every time they were arresting him,
he's got silver in his face.
He likes that color of March,
2009.
February,
2000.
Why are they going back and forth?
Rowdy Roddy huffer over.
It doesn't make any sense.
They went from March to a
breakout or something going on?
Yeah.
What does he get?
Clumps in his beard.
All paint his beard,
but this is going backwards.
This is February.
This is going January.
Like how is it going backwards?
It's such a bad huffing problem,
but this is weird because it's
not showing like a progression.
It's showing a regression.
Oh,
okay.
But that's 2008 back in time backwards.
Just to show you how
long he's been doing it.
He actually looks better
because of huffing paint,
I think in huffing paint might
be actually good for this dude.
He's like,
you don't get it.
Oh my God.
They busted him huffing paint.
2000 and 5,003 was huffing paint
all over his face.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Oh Jeez.
Eight first busted in [inaudible] 98 why?
He was like,
Whoa,
what's that?
He's the captain and anneal.
This guy looks so different.
He could be an actor.
It's going to end on [inaudible]
95 I feel like we should do a
documentary around that guy.
Give Him all the painting,
wants it,
faces of death.
Ask him what he feels about life.
Give them like certain subjects
and ask him to expound.
Yeah,
just film for like 10 hours and you can
get 40 minutes of wisdom out of that.
Do you think he started with
sharpies and then he graduated?
I remember as a kid
just sniffing sharpies.
Yeah.
Get them right up to my nose.
Just,
Yup.
Yeah.
Especially those fat ones.
The fact silver ones.
Yeah.
The best.
What is it about certain smells like that?
Gasoline.
So what it is,
it's the best.
No,
it's just that gasoline.
The smell of alcohol,
like rubbing alcohol.
Right.
But what is it about those
smells that like attracts people?
Because it's like you want to keep it.
We all love it so hard.
Everybody does.
Yeah.
I'd never met anybody who
doesn't like the smell markers.
Do you like smell Marcus?
Jamie?
Yes.
He says,
yeah,
he's got a marker right there.
He's practicing Brian.
I,
yeah,
but I used to hate the smell of skunks,
but now as a pot smoker,
I love skunks.
I loved the smell of shut
downs when I was let off.
That's interesting.
Do you know that it was explained to
me or I read it somewhere actually that
the,
when you smell skunk smell,
that's how good a dog's nose is,
is that skunk is such a particularly
strong smell that you could smell it and
like just a few parts
per million in the air.
That's why like you can be driving on
the street and you could smell a skunk
that's nowhere near your car,
right?
It's like nowhere near,
not even a hundred feet from
your car and you smell a skunk.
How the fuck can you smell it?
It's gone.
Well that's how a dog is with everything.
That's why dogs can like find dudes that
are like running through the woods by
sniffing their socks.
They're like sniff the guys sock.
They get a set and they
go off like they just,
they just,
just like,
you could smell a skunk like,
oh,
it's over here.
It's over here.
Like you know like roughly as
you're walking in the street,
if you're getting closer
to where that skunk is,
which is incredible.
If you think about,
there's no other smell like that for us.
We're just such a small amount.
Maybe they'll stink.
Bomb things.
Remember those fucking things
they used to throw in school?
Oh yeah.
The little Capri Sun bags of us.
Think those little things.
Well,
there will,
when I was a kid,
they were like these little glass vials
and they would throw them in the ground,
shadow them and the whole school,
it's just stink.
One asshole threw him in the ventilation
system of the air conditioning system.
That's all right.
Yeah.
He fucked the entire room up like the,
the whole class had to get evacuated.
It was so bad.
Like he just thrown it into the system,
went out into the hallways.
It's,
everybody was gagging.
We didn't have stink bombs.
But one time a girl threw up fruit roll
up next to me and I can still smell it.
It smells good fruit roll
ups for me for forever.
Yeah.
I guess when you get a,
um,
when someone throws up around you,
your immediate instinct is
to throw up because like,
it could be that it's food poisoning and
that you react to that you all ate the
same food and you realize that they're
getting sick and before your body can
digest it,
you just,
your body goes,
oh,
this is bad food.
So if you smell someone puking,
you just start
Puca.
Yeah,
that's,
that's amazing.
I love that stuff,
that natural,
uh,
like what's the one with,
um,
like women and like if
you smell a woman and,
and uh,
like there's like a stink that you like,
then that means that
you're like far genetically
apart.
Like a bad wiper.
Exactly.
Fairmont.
What are you saying is that
you have different genes?
You're not related in any way,
so it makes them more attractive.
Yes.
So it'd be good to breed with that person.
Right,
right.
Which is amazing,
but that throw up on,
that's a great one.
I've always wondered why that is,
but I always wondered,
you know,
whether or not certain levels of diversity
is attracting attractive to people at
sexual diversity.
Just because of like your
genetics want to mix things up.
You know what I mean?
Like a lot of guys have Asian fetishes
or maybe Norwegian fetishes like blondes,
they're like big blondes.
You know what I mean?
Like people get these [inaudible]
and like what is that?
It's like,
well you want to introduce those genes
into your genes and just like push that
new system out there.
That's the combination because if you
make close to your genes then yeah,
it could end up to formed or whatever.
Yeah.
Like it's very rarely see like
an all blonde couple blonde guy,
blond girl.
Well nothing wrong with loving blondes,
but you have dark hair.
So it's kind of like,
makes sense,
right?
Like so nineties like blondes mean girls.
I just like bonds like one guys.
Do you ever go to the beach and
go a surfer trolling or something?
More dudes at Surf Blonde.
Okay,
there you go.
Cause that's a fucking
stereotype right there.
That is a surfer dudes are kind of dopey.
You would assume they're blondes.
Hey,
what's up?
Didn't I see you on like a leeches?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but you assume they're idiots.
I do.
Yeah.
Right.
And bleaches their brain to,
yeah,
like a guy with a nice blonde hair.
It will probably never be president.
What's his Fox News anchors?
You Know Sandy,
it's gotta be saying,
I wonder is there anything like did the
stereotype of dumb blondes is a very
common stereotype?
What is in that?
What's that about?
Is that just that we men prefer blondes
so some bonds don't have to work as hard
because they're blonde.
Or is there some weird link between
having like light hair and lower
intelligence?
I think it's a little bit of both.
There must be some blonde geniuses though.
Yeah,
I think it's a cultural thing.
I really,
I like,
yeah,
like surfer Dude Valley girl.
That's what I picture blonds like pop
culture went a little bit overboard and
that's what everyone thinks of now.
Look bonds more rich white women and
they're the ones that are at home
like with handbags and like,
I think that's what it,
that's where it came from.
Rich white women in their fucking hands.
Yeah.
Am I getting really racist at all?
No,
not at all.
The part where you said every
race looks alike was perfect.
Yeah.
So except white people.
Right.
Um,
but yeah,
jelly,
the blonde thing,
like at the playboy level,
like playboy playmates were
all blonde for a while.
Like that was the
stereotypical playboy playmate,
right.
Blonde,
blue eyes.
Right.
Like how'd that happen?
Like what,
what is the best
Hugh Hefner just being,
uh,
a fetishist.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like Mitzi,
they used to say that Mitzi hated blondes
because she was a Brunette and she was
the queen of the comedy store.
So like,
I guess it was like impossible for a
blonde girl that even not only not get
passed at the store,
but it was hard for them to get
waitressing jobs at the store.
I've missed,
he just had this horse and all the
cute little brunettes everywhere.
But
yeah.
Well Dude,
you know like people like Mitzi shore,
like really like harsh,
like very eccentric people.
Like one person like that in an
ecosystem can change the entire,
like,
like with comedy,
one person like her change
comedy would be realistic.
Like that club and like her contributions
and her insistence on keeping it
crazy.
Yeah.
The,
all the madness that she would do.
She would take comics that don't like
each other and she put them back to back
with each other.
So they had to introduce
each other always.
Oh.
And all that shit that she did.
Like letting the comics run that place.
Yeah,
the loan it takes run the asylum,
you know,
she,
she created like this
whole like comedy movement.
If you think about all the,
the guys that came out of that
place Kennison and prior and like,
you know,
Letterman list goes on and on and on.
Man.
A lot of it because that one lady,
no,
Wendy and in Denver,
where are you going to be?
January,
but the January 2nd and third.
Oh good Lord.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Tony Hinchcliffe comes to
Denver all weekend long.
Golden Pony triumphantly rides into town
during the fucking part of the winter.
God,
Lord,
that'd be cool.
Little bit.
Tony,
warm your heart.
That's the pony riding into Denver.
That's the thing about Denver.
Even when it's cold,
it's sunny out.
It's not even depressing.
It's just cold.
Yeah.
When they went,
I was there with you.
Uh,
and when you did your taping,
there was some amazing fun
facts on the wall like that.
It has more sunny days than
San Diego and stuff like that.
That dude,
it's,
it's sunny.
It's fuck.
Yeah.
It's one of the coolest
cities on the planet earth.
Denver.
Absolutely.
One of the best spots ever,
and now with the weed and fusion,
that place is out of town.
They're just going crazy.
Yeah,
there's,
apparently they passed it.
They pass legal weed in Washington DC.
I don't know what you've seen that,
but there's some new
challenge to it by this,
a local politician who's being paid off
a congressman who's being paid off by
pharmaceutical companies.
This guy named Harris from Maryland.
He just led the charge to overturn the
will of Washington DC voters by inserting
language into Congress,
spending bill that prevents a district
from implementing the referendum.
They passed to legalize recreational
marijuana and the 2014 midterm election,
the referendum,
by the way,
passed with 70% of the
vote on election day.
So this hunt,
he introduced language into
a bill sneakily stopping
this from passing when 70%
of the population want it.
And when they asked him about it,
he said that relaxing marijuana laws
clearly leads to more teenage drug use,
which is just a lie.
That's just not true.
It's just not true.
According to Gallup,
polls obviously pulls her full shit,
but marijuana use amongst 18 to 20 wine,
nine year olds has fallen 20% since
1985 so even though we'd is way more
accessible than ever before,
it's continued to drop
because it's not a sneaky now.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's not as thrilling because
it's like everyone's smoking.
Yeah.
We all know that effect.
People don't like people
telling them what to do.
Exactly.
You know,
tell your kids what to do.
They're going to rebel.
The cops.
Kids always want to being criminals
are doing something fucking crazy.
I dated a girl in high school
that was went to Catholic school.
Yeah.
Oh you dirty girl.
I wouldn't shut it.
Only want to hear anymore.
I went to Catholic school too.
Did you?
Yeah,
the girls.
It's really,
I'd imagine regular
here moving a all girls.
No,
it's tough though man.
I'm telling Ya because that's hard to go
to school with girls wearing skirts and
the girls were all super cute and they'd
roll their skirts up and I remember,
Hey I,
I had a boner like eight
hours a day going to school.
You'd have to try to like
settle it down before the,
before class would end just
because you had to walk,
it was a big school,
three floors and you'd have to take the
stairs so you couldn't have the boner in
between classes.
So you'd have to like focus on other
things like your school work for the last
couple of minutes to get the bone or away.
Those 1617 year old boners are so
different to oh they have just throbbing,
throbbing and they're re
relatively recent in your life.
So they're incredibly confusing.
Like if you're 30 and you've been
getting boners since you were 15 that's
normal.
It seems like,
oh well here's a boner again,
I know how to deal with this.
But when you're 15 you're like,
oh,
I don't know what to do.
You're so confused.
Like the power it has over your system
is you are dealing with millions of years
of DNA that's telling you to breed and
you're trying to find someone to do this
with.
It's all going on be internally
like behind the scenes,
but socially and culturally you're
your face with repression and
slut shaming and worry and fear
of pregnancy and fear of disease.
And there's all this shit going on that
confuses this like natural weird thing
that your body is going through.
Your body just wants to fuck you know
when you're 16 that I remember that being
so confusing,
like relatively like having a relatively
good control over my life until I
started getting boners.
And then you know,
you wind up be like,
what the fuck?
Like who am I?
But I remember specifically is how much
more powerful the Boehner was that like
not only does a throb but it also,
I don't know if this
happened with you guys,
but mine would stick
just like straight up.
It's not like it is now where like if it,
if it happens then it's just a boner.
But it would be like star pointed more
northward like a fucking compass or
something.
You can go back there with a boner pills.
Well and were confused at why teachers
are having sex with 17 year old boys.
They have throbbing dicks.
Oh my God.
Well I mean someone's sounds
like they want to fuck some kids.
No.
Yeah,
I get it.
Yeah.
If you or your husband is like barely
hard and there's some 16 year old kid,
it's just rock cars flash
putting his leg to this side.
Yeah.
You're seeing the outline
of it in his pants.
He has to talk to you about football
practice and I just get so confused during
football practice and it's a waste line.
A lot of time something happens in my
legs get numb and that's where you have to
hide it.
You have to hide it up top.
You can't go any other
direction with that.
You have to go along the belt and
like pull your shirt out a little bit.
Untuck the shirt or you got
to get into sweatshirts.
Right.
Long ones,
they're a little bit too long for you.
They'd go down,
they'd cover,
cover your package and then you have
to carry your books in front of it all.
Yeah,
regulating kids.
Having sex is one of the most ridiculous
things ever are trying in any way to
regulate kids or it's stopped them.
Then when they're trying to pull that,
push that abstinence like that's the best.
Abstinence is the best way to
deal with sex with children.
Just keep them from having sex.
Abstain,
abstain,
abstain.
It's like saying don't
eat to hungry people.
It's like getting hungry people and
putting in a room full of food and saying,
don't eat.
That's how babies are made.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
But not telling them like,
look,
you know,
wear a condom or get on the pill.
Like something needs to happen here.
You guys can't just be
shooting loads of each other.
You're 15 can't make kids.
You know,
you could if we were living 10,000 years
ago and nobody had invented schools
yet.
But that's the other thing about schools,
it's like we take kids and we take
them away from the people that they're
learning from,
which is adults and we stick them with
mostly other kids and a couple parents or
rather adults that barely
can control the room.
So that becomes as Lord of
the flies type situation.
Like almost immediately when you get
more than 30 kids in a classroom.
And most classrooms today
because of budget cuts like
fucking 40 people and shed
40 kids in the class.
One teacher,
good luck control and
those little animals,
good luck.
And then they just start
fucking each other,
right?
A little while.
Monkeys,
Whoa,
stop them.
They're having parties.
Parents are going out of town.
It's fucking banging each
other and going nuts.
The band kids where the horniest band.
God.
Yeah.
Well you were so horny.
I don't know.
They were all fucking
each other all the time.
Hi.
This sounds like the most awesome opening
to like a porn girls describing her.
It was always the band kid.
She goes back to our memory.
It's like a younger,
Kim was like a camp outfit on Tuba.
Where are you guys going?
Why are you going to hike
with all your instruments?
Where we're going to go
play over in this field?
Do you want to come?
Yeah.
You'd come over the top of the crest.
The hill and it's just dope.
Fucking orgy.
Just to buzz.
Yeah.
Gang brains and fucking,
I like the thought of someone just having
a triangle that just came for the sex.
Yeah.
Some do with fucking Morocco's.
Yeah,
right guys.
So are we doing this or was,
what are those things?
Stumbles.
Not Assemble.
What are those?
The assemble tambourine.
Tambourine.
That's an asshole instrument.
If you choose a tambourine,
if you'd like,
I'd take a tambourine,
well,
you just want to annoy people.
Right?
And they're like to marine.
It can make certain songs
have a little depth,
but if that's all you got,
you're an asshole.
Yeah.
I'll give you show up and you're like
doing a like on the side of the street
doing a street performer thing and
it's with a tambourine good luck bitch.
You're going to starve to death.
Yeah.
Let me just give you money to annoy him.
What the fuck?
His stupid tamber Brody Stevens.
I love Brody.
He always has that tambourine
kick his fucking around.
Brody Stevens.
You know what he does do though?
That's hilarious.
He plays drums on chairs.
If you ever seen Brody do that.
Oh yeah.
He's really good at the drums,
so bust out chairs for drums
and just start playing.
I'm like,
he's playing drums and
go off like it's real.
Did it do?
Yeah.
That's one of those late night old school,
original room comedy
store set type things.
You know,
you see him doing that takes great pride
in inventing the art of chair drumming.
Yeah.
Brody Stevens,
another one at the commissary.
Is there anybody that
does the tambourine well,
I guess they're like the lost
art of the tambourine fought.
See if you can find awesome
Maureen performance.
Not Try that way.
You never know.
Somebody might know how to rock it,
right?
Yes.
Somebody's mind.
Yeah.
I've thought that before.
I remember putting a tweets.
Has Anyone ever really mastered
the tambourine this thing?
You're just thinking about it.
How would you know?
We'd have to go look,
right?
Yeah.
Do you remember like school plays when
they did the musicals and they gave all
the shitty kids?
That one little thing,
thing,
xylophone.
They gave the shitty kids that
couldn't play in the musical.
They're like,
you just tap this one.
You know what's really funny when you're
like for that thing is to shit dope as
fuck.
All kids gravitate towards that.
It's a trap because there's not a
lot of longevity in the xylophone.
Like you start,
you start out thinking,
yeah,
I'm a fucking head of the curve.
Yeah,
but you got to know when to bail on the,
that's just bongos,
dude.
That's the tambourine in between his legs.
Oh,
no way.
Yeah,
he made it an art.
Oh his hair's
so that's the guy that was huffing.
Uh,
he's actually playing the drums though.
I don't understand.
That's the tambourine is
making the drum sound as well,
right?
Yeah.
I'm counting on the top of the temporary.
Pretty okay.
I have to take it back
cause that's pretty dope.
You don't like it.
Does that count as playing?
Just the tambourine?
Yeah,
he's using the tambourine
but not play itself.
No,
that is,
that's the tambourine tambourine.
He has an in between his legs instead
of holding it like you normally see it.
I could see like a wild,
crazy eccentric man.
It has.
Is his bedroom done up like a
jungle at any brings you in and lazy
John on a Hammock and then he puts this
this CD on and it's all just this guy
playing jungle tambourine
music and the guy comes down,
we'll look fucking feathers
around his wrist and shit.
Some wild boar.
Your head dress on.
He fucks this kind of music.
Yeah.
You couldn't see this.
Oh,
I can totally picture that.
I could see you doing that Tony.
Well,
you know,
I've been known the bus stop.
A tambourine for sure.
Time to time.
I don't see playing it.
I see you putting that music on the
background showing up with like face paint
on this war path.
Whoa.
Yeah.
This is actually seen from
less the chick from bedrooms,
right?
That's Mama from good times,
Huh?
If church was like that long ago,
Trish,
for black people's way better
than church for white people,
Gary Owens is a whole bit about it.
They turn up,
turn up,
turn up for what they turn up or turn
down for water and I'm for Jesus her down
for what?
You see that video turn down for what?
A fucking little John Video.
It's the greatest music video
in the history of the world.
Brian counts sent it to me.
He goes,
this is the greatest thing
you'll ever watch your life.
And I was like,
are you really making me
watch a little John Video?
And then halfway into it I realized,
oh my God,
it's the greatest thing
I've ever seen in my life.
Turn down for what?
He's great.
It's a wild motherfucker.
New Mountain Dew Dorito flavor.
That's the students to do.
We
see a guy like a little
John is a perfect example.
Why everybody shouldn't like take
a standard path through life.
You know,
high school,
College,
get your shit together.
Four O one k plan.
No,
no,
no.
You d like in order for a dude to have
diamonds all over his teeth and be some
crazy motherfucker,
you need to have an eccentric childhood.
You know,
you need to have a,
uh,
a very unusual path and upbringing.
You know,
you don't just make a little John.
He is so cool in real life.
I hung out with him.
We had a crazy night in Nashville.
We both have a mutual friend who
flew us out for his birthday party,
like this blowout 50th birthday
party for John Rich big musician.
And uh,
I roasted him.
He flew me,
Jeff Ross and Sarah Tiana to his 50th,
well his wife did to roast him.
He has like a house of Blues in his house.
He has a big five story house
on a mountain in Nashville.
John Rich Shit.
So and I roasted a,
I roasted lulled John too cause he
was out in the audience but I had to,
you know,
I had to acknowledge them.
Right,
right,
right.
And uh,
did you have a song?
What else is on when he's in the audience?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He had everything.
He had the whole look I go nowadays
when Lil Jon is yelling what?
It's because he's gotten old
and he couldn't hear you.
Huh?
The sunglasses.
That's the,
if you were on $25,000 pyramid,
that would be under things only
black people can wear at night.
Sunglasses.
You would,
that would be like one of the first ones.
Black people in Bondo.
That's it.
You but Bondo.
I had to say that he had glaucoma
cause people are like what the fuck?
Bano yeah,
you're always wearing sunglasses but
black people can just get away with it.
And Floyd Mayweather
every interview he does,
he wear sunglasses,
he gets interviewed,
does award shows,
wear sunglasses,
walks up to the deus with sunglasses
on and no one says anything.
If a white guy tried to do that,
can you imagine if like,
okay,
like a famous white boxer like Vladimir
Klitschko heavyweight champion.
If he showed up with
sunglasses on and they're like,
that motherfucker isn't even
train and he went Hollywood.
Yeah.
Look at him.
White guys wearing like sunglasses
indoors or at night shows a lack of
dedication to your craft.
Right?
It looks a lot douchey
or when white guys do it,
I think,
why is that what it feels like
the right like rock and roll vibe.
Then maybe you could work Elvis keeping
it around David Lee Roth can do whatever
the fuck he wants to
tell you that right now.
Like a rock and roll vibe.
It works the way I call it David.
The Rock can do whatever the fucking
lost Schaefer with Joe Perry when we had
Joe Perry and Joe Perry could do whatever
the fuck you want slash slash can do
whatever the fuck he wants.
Axl rose though.
If he's wearing sunglasses,
you're like,
you're high bitch.
Me John was,
that was Paul Paul Shaffer.
He could basically do
whatever the fuck he wants.
Yeah,
he's eccentric.
He's allowed to.
Elton John told him he
used to wear those glasses.
Can do anything.
That's the one exception.
Every fucking roll.
Huh?
You could wear a wig,
put on crazy glasses.
He can fucking wear silly hats.
You can do anything you
want to Rod Stewart,
wear glasses.
He could do whatever the fuck he wants.
He wrote Maggie Mae.
This is like if you get one wake
up Maggie song in your life,
you know that song just knocked
it out of the fucking park.
He's,
he's done for life.
He's always rod Stewart.
Yeah.
No matter where he goes
to the rest of his life.
That's Rod motherfucker store.
Me Too.
When I was 15 and I didn't appreciate it.
So we left early.
Oh No.
Yeah.
We didn't even wear like
this fucking is weird.
He's wearing weird pants.
Let's get outta here.
You definitely,
where were pants?
Yeah.
And it was just like all these older
people like dancing in the front and we're
like,
he's moody,
like angry teenagers that
their bangs to the side.
Oh
that song is so God damn good.
He's got a bunch of songs that are so gap.
God damn good.
But then he went like disco later.
Yeah,
you got it.
Like that disco phase.
You know the early shit is
like my favorite shit of his,
but then he got like,
he got that sexy song.
Yeah.
Few bought my body started
looking like a bird.
It just wasn't the same shit.
You know,
it's like that was like,
it was more of a lego lower
frequency than the old,
like Maggie Mae's like this
deep rich storytelling song.
And we know when that song resets three
fourths of the way through and that
mandolin comes through.
If you don't get the chills,
kill yourself.
I like a song about a chick
fucking up a dude's life too.
I liked that.
I like hearing those songs.
I support that.
Yeah.
Do you girls find it's hard
to date guys cause they wear,
you put them in their act,
your act or other,
no,
they're just not as funny to me because
guys try to impress girls by being
funny.
Right.
And I'm constantly around the
funniest and so I'm just like,
Ooh,
this is terrible.
It's off,
right?
Yeah.
It's weird situation.
Cause then it sometimes I'm like,
oh,
maybe I should just wait like a
bank teller and then I'm like,
oh,
this is so boring and lame.
And then you know,
you don't want to date
someone that's always busy.
Like you said,
it's like date yourself,
wasn't it?
There's also the weird thing about,
um,
comedians is that you guys go on stage.
I mean,
we all go on stage like
pretty much every night.
So every night like you like,
you know,
they're like,
hey,
let's go do this and go to Napa.
You're like,
I've got to do a set.
Yeah.
You know,
especially like when you're
really like right now,
like how you are right now,
right.
How I am right now,
where you're in the middle of like a
bunch of new bits and were like super
excited about all these new bits.
Those you gotta you gotta
feed those bitches every day.
Like you can't just let
them say you have a new bit.
You can't put that fucker
on the shelf at all.
Right?
You got to jump on it
and keep watering it.
Nobody wants to hear that
shit if you're dating them.
Oh,
you care about is your fucking jokes.
Just want to go to the comedy club
and make a bunch of dudes laugh.
Is that what it is?
Fucking cute up there.
Yeah.
Is Your Dick Paying me?
What if they said yeah,
yeah.
No pain.
Which pay?
What's a bitcoin?
Apparently there's a Toyota dealership
that just started accepting bitcoin for
payment for fucking cars in Palm Beach,
Florida and Microsoft
start accepting bitcoin.
Microsoft started to invent a
accepting bitcoin for their APP,
their APP APP,
whatever it is.
Store they call the
store market at market,
whatever the fuck it is.
Nice.
I don't even get it.
Me Neither.
Is it kind of take off?
Is it worth learning about?
Yes.
Yeah.
If you listen to this podcast with a,
um,
Andrea has Antonopoulos
this guy that we had on,
we found him on three times and every
time he talks I get more and more
convinced and the Fizz,
the third last third latest podcast,
I'm like,
this shit actually has a
chance and cause half list.
Yeah.
Isn't that the Brown
elephant from Sesame Street?
I'm a grown man.
That's different.
That's the guy you never see.
Yeah.
Snuffaluffagus he never say Antonopoulos
he's been on the podcast times.
Oh,
okay.
Pay attention span.
Anyway.
Um,
he's,
he's convinced in the,
in the value of digital currency.
He's absolutely convinced and convincing.
He's a brilliant guy.
So when he talks about it and he's
as knowledgeable about Bitcoin,
has anybody explains the algorithm behind
creating it and he explains like why
it's viable and why
companies jumping on board.
Paypal uses it now.
Dell computers uses it now.
Tiger direct uses it now.
I mean,
it's getting to the point where popup up,
boop,
boop.
Companies just up and up
are starting to use it.
And if it becomes an
accepted form of currency,
boy that's going to get really weird.
It didn't even exist three years ago.
So you gotta think like three,
four,
five years ago,
there was no bitcoin.
Right?
So what is it gonna be like
five years from now if you could
buy a car with it today?
Wow.
Yeah.
I saw an ATM,
a Bitcoin ATM and
Hollywood and I was like,
what is that?
What is that?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that going to be
able to adopt kids with bitcoins?
Does the thing be paid or adopt kids?
Do you have a plan to
buy them with bitcoins?
No.
To like never have a
kid just to adopt one,
but that way you pay for it.
Oh No,
I need to have a kid.
I think my plan is to marry like someone
that's down to be like a house dad.
I've been like let me make money
and you want to marry a bitch?
No.
Like he needs to be mainly too like you
can check off what in the yard by the
way.
I'm joking.
Did,
if you're a house dad,
you're a bitch.
No,
the the traditional roles of
a mother and father and uh,
you know,
like I have a friend who's
essentially a house mom.
His wife has his very high powered
job and he's a professor at Stanford.
He teaches like a couple of days a week,
but other days he's home.
He's,
he saw him all the time with his kids and
he's the one who's around them all the
time
and it works.
That's part,
that's one of those hard parts about being
a woman comedian too and like wanting
a family because where you have a
biological clock and I'm also working,
it's like Manhattan,
take their time and get,
establish and be 70 year old millionaire
and then find some like hot young girl
to impregnate.
But we have like a,
we have to do it like now
it's like now or never.
Yeah,
yeah.
You have to trick a guy quick,
full.
Like
how rude.
You don't agree Sam.
I'll fucking rude.
I feel like,
who wants to feel like the old
data misses like their kids stuff?
The dads with like millions
and millions of dollars.
I'm thinking like that.
They're just being selfish.
Probably.
You know,
when you see like a 65
year old guy who has a kid,
they're not thinking,
you know,
like,
boy,
uh,
I know I'll be here 40 years from now
when I'm 105 this kids set and I'm going
to be in his life.
No,
they're just having a kid.
Yeah.
I mean maybe it's good.
Maybe it's bad.
You know,
who knows?
I mean,
I think that's the thing
about human beings.
He's like even under less
than ideal circumstances,
a lot of times cool people come out of it.
Yeah.
It's a real dilemma involved in raising
kids because you want to protect your
kids,
but the reality is adversity builds
character and meeting weird people,
shitty people mean people like it
gives you like a database to draw from.
And then the other thing,
we've talked about this before,
but being around people who are kind of
shitty makes you appreciate people who
are really cool.
What are you doing with
your hand gestures?
10 minutes.
Okay.
I wasn't sure it was behind me.
And then you smelled your own arm.
And then I smelled my microphone
and caught a whiff and was like,
oh,
it's just me.
Oh,
good Lord,
Lord.
Um,
so kill Tony is on the
desk quad podcast network.
It's on pretty much,
you guys do it once a week,
right?
I mean,
the comedy store every
Monday night at eight,
every Monday night live the comedy store.
If somebody wants to get tickets,
did they buy them in advanced?
Do they get them at the
door reservations online?
Or You could just economy store's website.
Yeah.
So go to [inaudible] dot com and a desk,
squad.tv for all the links to
all the podcasts and audio,
video and audio,
and a also tour schedule
for all the Brian shows,
all the ones that you do with Tony.
And I mean,
you're constantly doing stuff on the road.
You got some shit coming up,
right?
And we have a good one.
Next Wednesday.
We're having a benefit
show at the comedy store.
Uh,
Jeff Ross is,
he's probably going to do it.
We end and Kim might actually be roasting,
doing a quick roast at the beginning.
Uh,
because all the money is going towards
buying a new sound system in a,
in the belly room where kill Tony's
recorded and where the roast battles
recorded.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you gotta check it out at Joe.
Joe Said,
you're said you're going
to do it also and yeah,
I'm going to do it also.
I'm Secura and that's going to be great.
We're going to get all new speakers in
the belly rooms at the live shows better.
Yes.
Shows taking place on that right now.
It's all going through.
You would never believe it if you looked
at it for the energy that's in those
rooms during roast battle and kill Tony,
it's all coming through to
little tiny like bathrooms,
speakers,
how much the speakers cost.
I don't know.
W W W I told the general
manager was just go in there,
you know,
knew cause they need a new sound board.
Also the soundboards just
as shitty sound byte.
It's been destroyed a thousand times.
And so just to get a quote
and then whatever it is,
we'll just put it towards whatever.
That sounds dope.
So we can maybe do a few shows if
you don't make the money in one show.
Yeah.
Do a few shows.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think that's what it is.
My friends.
So that's the 17th
right?
Yeah,
the 17th eight 30 a comedy Stuart's Cami,
store.com.
That's a Wednesday too,
right?
Wednesday,
December,
December 17th that day I have
Ron Finley on the podcast.
He's that guy that's
growing a farms in uh,
in La,
in the inner city.
He's doing like these urban farms or he's
helping people grow their own food and
these like abandoned lots and
teaching them how to grow healthy,
nutritious food in like Compton and
watts and shit like that in Inglewood.
It's really bad ass.
Something that we've been
talking about for a long time.
Like,
like people like,
like the cost of food,
like how difficult it is to like get
food and like why don't we have like
community farms where like the whole
block is responsible for like one,
one area where we all grow vegetables
and we all get the food from that and we
distributed evenly amongst each other.
This guy's doing that.
Amazing.
Yeah,
he's got a Ted talk on it,
so he's going to be there,
uh,
on the podcast that same day.
Okay,
cool.
Very cool indeed.
Anything to add?
Toner,
Denver,
Denver.
I love coming.
Wendy is the best.
And she told me that,
that I'm headlining.
I can't even believe it.
So please come see me
January 2nd and third.
It's a really big deal for him.
Yeah.
And uh,
Tony will be with me tomorrow night.
We will be together with Young Ari Shaffir
Aka the renegade Jew super twink and
the renegade Jew at the
celebrity theater in Phoenix.
The celebrity theater spins in a circle.
It's like a theater in the round,
which is pretty interesting.
Um,
and people get to look at your ass.
We're on stage and I'm so
excited to call it that.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to stuff it with
the toilet paper or something.
Oh,
I thought you were gonna
say like CIA style.
They were stuffing
people's asses with food.
Do you hear about that?
Oh yeah.
You're actually feeding them to
get them to give up information.
I'll tell you what,
I'm never more truthful than when
you're shoving crackers into my ass.
Yeah.
That's when I really come with the truth.
I'll rat out anybody sense
like what kind of an asshole?
I guess the only way you can fucking
get that guy to talk to guy in his ass.
So on a ritual.
Oh No,
not that cucumber.
Obama's.
Hmm.
All right.
Uh,
all right,
so we will be back podcast wise.
We'll be back on Monday,
my friends.
So until then,
go fuck yourself.
Have A,
have a beautiful life.
A hug your kids.
Pet your cat.
Uh,
tomorrow night.
See you guys in Phoenix.
Oh,
um,
Twitter pages.
Ladies.
Uh,
at Kim.
Really Congdon spell that shit.
A c.
O n g.
D.
O N.
Kimberly.
And you have a,
an odd or one mine is Princess
Shank is so princess like normal.
And then another ass of
three houses in a row.
H e n k,
Sarah wine shank and Kimberly Condon,
renegades of comedy warriors of joke
telling kill Tony on the desk squad that
work.
All right,
coach,
kill Tony Pod.
Also kill Tony Pod.
Okay.
All right.
We love you guys and we'll see you soon.
Bye.